This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress,
the only online mattress company to
provide free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Christina,
I don't know if I'm supposed to
say the word men are just mia h.
It's Ob one copy one. Can only
hope guys a hit maker. Yes.
Dang.
All different kinds of music too. So
talented music people, hip hop stuff.
Edm stuff sends me golf trax.
Okay.
I make pornos his shit.
I'm digging it, man. Do
you want to go ahead?
What you doing homie?
Okay,
I like to thank everybody who came
out to Madison. Uh, was come on.
Your [inaudible] sold out shows amazing.
Everybody was so kind. Thank you.
Uh, rolling along on the ride or die tour.
April four through six mini apple tits,
Minnesota Acme comedy club.
May 10th and 11th,
10 PE at the Tempe Improv in Arizona.
May 31st through June 1st here
in sperm, Maine, California,
the flip Paris Comedy Club,
June 20th through 22nd Washington.
Dick come at the Dick.
Come improv tickets at Christina p online.
I got a lot of dates coming
up. Other cities, I'm not
going to announce just yet,
but they're common.
I'm going across America guys,
and also if you're new to me,
to the podcast I have to Netflix,
standup specials,
mother inferior and I have a half hour
called the degenerates with Joey Coco
Diaz. Oh, Christian Gleesa has been
a guest on the show, so check it out.
Try it out.
Jean Jean,
Jean. Jean. Chink. Chink,
Chink, Chink, Chink. Yeah.
Yeah. Studio G. Yes.
I'm going to be a flow rider. No Way.
This is going up in another week. Okay.
Portland, Maine. Let's see. All those are
sold out. There's some late show tickets.
March 30th in new haven at the John
Lyman Center for the performing arts.
Early Show is sold out.
A couple tickets left for the late show.
Then I'm really excited about April.
Uh,
you can get tickets to the lake
show in Wisconsin, in Madison,
Wisconsin at the Orpheum,
the late show in Milwaukee
at the Riverside theater
and the late show on Sunday,
April 14th in Nashville
at the Ryman Auditorium.
From there,
April goes from Bethlehem to Boston.
The only show you can get into in
Boston is April 28th at the [inaudible]
theater in Medford, Medford, Mia,
and then from there
Portland and meet rattle.
It's going to be a really fun time.
I thought of a new word for you
instead of Orpheus, the horror film.
That's really good. You got
it. You can. You can text the,
you know the comedy on
state people that they own,
that they own, that you tell
him I had a great idea today.
Does your marketing team know?
And she'll be like, cool.
Thank you very much for that suggestion
and nicest people at that club too.
Oh my God.
Really appreciate you calling it though.
Forefield now we would have done
without you, Christina. Thank you.
This show today is loaded.
You've got too much good
stuff to get into. Okay.
Let's go ahead and start the show.
Oh,
excuse me, sir. Excuse me. It's ma'am,
ma'am. I can call him. He likes
me too. You need to set down.
You need to settle down to find your
business, ma'am. Once again, man,
don't bring it in one loving
well. Well. Well, go to your mom's house
and
Christina.
Oh,
Ooh. Snap. Like, Hey, how
are you? What's your name?
What's Your Pronoun?
Really funny that you would ask?
What's your Pronoun Tom
Today? Um, he him. Wow.
Traditional Z's him. He, him. I'm always,
they you are. Well, yeah, I'm,
my gender is fluid throughout the
program. Oh, so you can go anywhere.
I could.
I started as a woman this morning,
but I'm feeling a little neutral right
now. I'm going to go anyway. Yeah.
That's nice. Yeah. So you feel
you've got coffee gendered?
Hey,
that's a new one.
Yeah. I really like
that. It's, what is she?
It's ma'am, ma'am, ma'am. Like Gosh,
she can't tell why somebody would
be confused by you. I mean the,
the righteous indignation
over the confusion.
Clearly
I respect and I really do. If anybody
was like, here's my my pronouns,
I'm going to call you by your
Pronoun Preferred Pronoun.
But you got to expect some
mistakes, you know, out of the gate.
Right.
There's no way you're walking around like
that because she looks like she could,
you know, start at
defensive tackle. Right.
Excuse me. It's ma'am, ma'am,
you need to settle down and mind
your business once again man,
I guess she is at game stop
or something like that. Yeah,
something like that. Let's just call
it a nondescript game store. Okay.
A nondescript game store trying
to I think make a return and uh,
I think it's, you know, she's being
offered to them as all game stores do.
You're like, I bought this for 60 bucks.
They're like, we'll give you $2. Okay.
So trying to maybe do a sale like
return or something like that. Um,
and then gets indignant,
very upset about,
I think the offer that's being made
for the game. And then his mis-gendered
uh,
both of you guys right beforehand,
your fucking
mother Fucker,
mother fucker.
And then she kicks over
to him merchandise there.
I like how her gender is fluid too,
because when she wants to be a surf,
she can be as hard as she did. Say,
I'll show you a search. She's like,
I'll fucking show you. So
that's, that's, that's pretty,
that's pretty fluid.
Talk. Call them and talk about how
it's misgendered several times. Oh,
I need your corporate number now.
Well,
I'm going to ask you for the fifth time
to stop calling me a man because quite
clearly I have not,
no,
clearly,
Ooh,
you're going to disrespect
and Trans people in the store,
which I plan on telling the entire Lgbtq
community who was mulling over this
damn hello. She's so up. It's almost
like I kind of feel bad,
you know? I do. I do.
Cause I imagine it's
very difficult when you,
when you are trying to present one way
people keep mis-gendering you and you're
like, dude, look, you know, but what
I learned from what was that show?
A lost in translation or trans
life for yeah. Yeah. One it,
those like the Tlc one is,
uh,
like I remember there was a
guy who was transitioning, uh,
Boston transition lost
in transition. Yeah. Um,
there was a guy who was transitioning to
a woman and had just basically started
and look like me with longer hair,
no beard,
but like big shoulders.
And she was getting her nails done
and somebody was like, hey man.
And she was like, God, why are people
calling me? Man. It was like, well,
cause you look like a fat guy
with a pink with a pink, um,
crop top, like the pink crop top
doesn't mask everything just yet.
I'd give it some time,
trap fool and shoulders.
I want to get my nails done. And they're
like, okay. And then so it was like sir.
And she was like, God
dammit, what do I gotta do?
I've been doing this for two weeks. I
don't know. You need a lot more surgery.
I know. And well, and too, I think I
would, it would be ruder of me to be like,
what should I call you? I don't know
what you are like, how should I,
what Pronoun should I call you? That
might be more rude. Really? Yeah.
Then just making an assumption expert.
Hey,
how are you? What's your name?
What's Your Pronoun? Yeah.
That's how you should do
it. Yeah. I don't know.
I would feel more rude to
anything. No. Now that I,
now that I hear it and I see this now,
I feel like you probably should,
but and you don't delete in is, you
know, just say what your Pronoun, it's,
what's your name? What's your name? Cause
sometimes someone's going to be like, oh,
it's Angela. And you'd be like, oh,
I was going to go. But if it's pat,
Chris Terry, yeah, but like then if
you're following it up, what you go,
what's your name?
What's Your Pronoun?
Then it's like you're trying to make an
effort and if they're like the fuck are
you asking me that?
I'm sorry.
And they're like, is Kyle my
God? What the fuck? I'm sorry.
I just thought maybe that you are. Well,
and here's the, here's the deal man.
Here's the problem is that a lot
of these I would, if I had another,
if I had more time in my life,
I would become like a trans coach
and I would help women dress.
Oh,
I see women dress like more feminine.
The problem is these patients are trying
to dress like they're a car Dashi and
hot and they were like
the Valore tracksuit.
That casual female style, like if
you're gonna, if you're a new female,
you got really fem it up so
that the public knows like, oh,
they're very much presenting as a
female. Yeah. You know what I mean? Yeah.
It's kind of go overboard and then dress
it up and then when you're more changed
then then you can dress down as a
hot chick. You know what I'm saying?
Like I go big dangly earrings,
real obvious rate, long, long,
long hair extensions and
shit. You can't be like, oh,
just like casually agile girl. No
Dude. Like I can pass as a fee.
This is casual girl.
How'd he saying?
I mean I present as a woman sometimes.
It's brings me to my next topic.
I was on the airplane traveling.
I don't know if you do this. I was
in Madison. Oh Dude, I big debts.
Now we're talking. That's my mom.
Yeah. She's got a big tits too.
She's got a big old and she
doesn't like to wear a Bra. Anyway,
so any huddles,
I don't know if you do this,
and I wrote this down because I
wanted to talk, talk about it.
When you're on a plane and you're in an
airport and you're looking at people,
and let me preface this,
preface this by saying it's so random
who you end up with in life, right?
It's crazy.
It's a matter of like that
night I could've gone out
with a different comedian,
a different person,
and then falling in love with somebody
else and now I have a totally different
life that doesn't involve
sold out theaters,
Ferrari's, Mcdonald's, sponsorships.
I mean I'm fucking ball.
I know and I,
that's why I preface,
I clearly made the right choice.
Ular but do you ever stop and
think like sometimes I'll be like,
what if I wasn't like with Tommy?
Like do you ever see people on the plane?
You're like,
what if that was my spouse all the time?
Really course.
But then I immediately find a flaw
and the stranger and I'll be like,
but we would never work
out because that guy,
we're top siders topsiders
with the gays thing.
And you always find something like where
you're like, man, yeah, I've got French.
She got French mannequin. Yeah, I
fucking hate French manic. Yeah.
And like I could never love somebody
with a fresh manic and then I feel like
telling her, I'd be like, you, you got a
lot going for you. But the solid color,
I feel like telling them too.
That's so funny. Like if, um,
like for instance in
Madison it was so cold,
it's like two degrees and then there's
a guy in front of me who gets on the
plane wearing shorts and sandals, sandals
and you're like, I could never love you.
I could never love you.
Because fundamentally we see the world.
So definitely as human
beings it's completely,
it should be mandatory that your mind
plays that game and your mind should also,
if you're somewhat, I mean,
unless you're like miserable,
but your mind should get to the
point where it goes like, oh,
but this wouldn't work out
the game that your mind plays.
I think everyone does that though.
Yeah. You see the person, you're like,
I can be married to you baby.
I don't ever think I go, I go like, I'll
see a nice looking guy and I'll be like,
I wonder what their light like,
what's wrong with that guy?
Because there's always some,
there's always a rub with people.
There's always there.
They're given,
they're taking their bad
sides and you're like, yeah,
what's the darkness and that person, like
what's their flaw? And then you know,
you make one up in your head and like,
I know that guys immediately
sometimes you'd be like, yeah,
if I was married to her,
then she starts talking.
You like this bitch never shuts
up. Or You'd be like, yeah,
it's just give good head.
You can see the way she's eating.
You can tell that just by watching it.
I'm just saying,
well in my head I'm making it up, but
she gets bad blow job. I'm like, yeah,
she doesn't use spit enough. You know?
She always neglects the balls. Yeah, yeah.
That's what you're worried about is the
blow job quality. Well also, you know,
like just conversation is a big way,
right? So I'll start being like,
oh yeah, that could be what
if I was married to her?
And then she starts talking.
I'm like, oh for fuck's sake. Yeah.
Like if I were married to
somebody who wasn't a comedian,
how difficult that would be for me
because then I'd have to pretend like I'm
this normal person all the time.
Yeah.
Because I did date an
attorney before you and eh,
when I became a comedian and it
ruined her. Do you ever have the ammo?
I've had it now where I've met
a few people and I have just a,
I dunno, I guess my professional
demeanor on with them, like just polite,
nice, you know, a couple of times. And
then they come to a show and they're like,
whoa. Yeah. You're like,
well that's really who I am.
Yeah.
You know, that would be likes I
met you at like whatever, you know,
accounting office or something.
Cause I like on this show,
I get to be myself 100% in our home
life. I'm 100% mean, but then if I,
you know, I'm at the airport or if I am,
I'm trying to be normal purse. It's a,
it's a concerted effort for me to hold
it together and not say what exactly what
I'm thinking all the time.
Of course it takes a very,
and you know what I love about you too
and I, I told you this the other day.
Why think I'm so lucky to have you.
I'm so messy. Yeah, you really brought,
you were really into that.
I'm so messy.
I just dropped and in 15 years
together you've never once been like,
God damn it. You pick up your fucking
underwear. Why don't you pick up your,
so like you've never done and you
let me wear any of your shirts to bed
cause I've had boyfriends in
the past who have been like,
you can't wear that shirt. That's
like my good one or what? I know.
Horrible people. Right. See that's why
I only can marry you bay. Of course.
No, but you never give me shit about it
either. I know. That's why we work out.
I know. Thank God you almost married
this guy on the plane though. There's no,
there's no like specific. Literally like
I'll be sitting. Did you touch his leg?
No. I'm sitting in a plane likes people
pass me by and I'd be like, can I,
can I love that person? I want to hear
about the ones. I love that person.
It's very specific for me. I
look to see some photos. Okay,
next time I find a guy I think I might
love if I could love that person started
doing the same thing. Think
I might love her. Yeah.
Could I love her? Could I love
that? I think I might love or it's,
can I love this person? And then
you have to find the flaw and then,
and then I'll be like, oh,
we hooked up. Oh No, no,
I fucked her and she,
now here's the game, Tom.
The game is stupid shit.
The game only lasts a total of 10
seconds by the way, last that long.
So if I haven't done it in a while,
no, I mean the game of everything.
10 seconds. No, no. Here's
the game. You're on a plane.
You're watching people filing,
you go, could I love this person?
And then within 10 seconds you find
the flaw and then you're like, I,
that's why I love my husband ones. If you
don't find the blog then are you like,
oh my God, that's the worst. No,
you'll always find the flaw because
then you don't find the pull in my mind
cause I go, I'll be like,
that guy's way too neat.
He would never put up with my message
is Tom puts up with, no, I know,
I see those type a women too who
are like, perfect. Oh my God.
You imagine how mad they would get
at me. Oh my God. What is this?
The farting and the burping. Scratching.
Scratching my arm pits. Yeah.
Yeah, that'd be like,
Oh shit. She be like,
Oh, you know, I did not sign up for this.
And like that's what you got
now was your new man, ain't no.
And then, um, so there's that story.
So play that with your spouse if you're
listening and I'm curious to see what
you guys come up with as
deal breakers with strangers.
Maybe run your finger along.
That's a fun game to play
with your spouse too.
You gotta know what your smells are.
You to learn to learn your smells,
smells in here. You should kind
of know them a little more.
Everybody knows their own smells. You
know you're asking him. I was like, yeah,
from running your finger along it.
I don't have to run my finger.
I feel like I just know that with every
narrow and then if you need a shower,
because my nuts
where those compression shorts to the
gym yesterday and then I didn't have time
to shower.
We went to that appointment.
Then I came back and men really stripped
down in the bathroom. I was like, whew.
Ripe. Really? Right. Do you
wash the shorts? I hope so. Nah,
I put it back on right
away. Yeah. Yeah. What the,
how many guys work kind of brew?
How many guys listening are like yeah,
just put it back on. Oh,
there's guys right now we're
like, oh, keep talking Tom.
That's hot stink.
So weird out coach. I wouldn't even
know what to do without coach. Yup. Um,
and so also another topic I wanted
to bring up is that when I was away,
when you came up, you have a new thing,
you've found the new show. Oh yeah.
I'm really excited and it actually
informed me and I think you're going to be
happy about this.
I now think it is stupid and
wasteful to get jewelry for my 40th.
Yes, thank you. Praise Jesus. You know
why there's no utility in jewelry.
You're absolutely 100% right.
So the idea that you would spend that
amount of money on something I just put
around my neck a silliness.
It's stupid. And Liz,
Danny Brown said someone could come
and snatch it. Exactly. You don't want,
that's why I want to refocus my efforts
and yours hopefully into getting a jet.
I was watching this show selling jets
where couples who look like they own jets,
we're buying jets.
And how much money do you think we have?
Like we don't Mcdonald's, we had to give
back the money. We don't have 2 million.
Here's the great thing I learned that
most jet brokers let you just put 20%
down. So it's like buying a house and
we just need, how much is 20% for a jet?
Well, that's the thing is that
there's so many options. You know,
like there's light jets, midsize
jets, super admid heavy. I mean,
I think right now we're probably looking
at like a super light or something.
You know? How much is that? I mean
that's the thing. I don't think Steve,
I don't want to get lost in
the weeds of the numbers.
I think it's just something that
it makes a lot of sense. Yeah.
So much more utility than a stupid
chain. You're so funny. I can, I know.
I can hear the future we have to get,
we also have to buy the helicopter
that goes with the jet way later.
That's like three years from now and then
we have to build the hell a pad on top
of the house.
That's a great idea to buy the yacht
with the helicopter landing pad. We have,
why do you have a chopper if you
can't land it on your yacht? Right.
Look all I'm here. Just a few loans. Yeah.
Okay. A few loans. We
got to get some loans,
how many millions of
dollars we're talking about.
That's the fun part is you can decide,
you know,
you just basically look at,
you know, your needs and,
um, person, here's the great thing.
I found out Rockefeller and his
[inaudible] found out that, uh,
through executive charter
services that manages these, uh,
chats,
we can bring down basically our whole
operating costs by at least 50% just by
chartering it out 150 hours a
year. I'm like, God, who are we?
I don't know. I just, you know, I
think it's a good idea. Anyways,
I'm turning 40 in a couple months and
I'm looking forward to seeing, uh,
in the driveway and I'm
like, God, do you get,
I would get, yes, but what
would our church think?
I mean, that's true. They don't,
we don't, you know what I mean?
They're gonna be like, wait, why aren't
you donating money to the church?
He should be giving it to us.
What can I say to get you to just
sign off on this jet ID thing?
There's nothing you can say that would
make this remotely logical. I got an idea.
I cannot, I'll donate some of my
flying hours to the church. Okay, good
deal. You got yourself a deal,
homie. You know important.
It is for the church,
me and my church.
I needed my priest to be able to
fly around in comfort. All right.
You have a point. Can we show up
and do it? No, no. It's insanity.
I mean it's you talking like a crazy
person. Is there one dream I can pursue?
He goes, support. Here's what, here's
what I will tell ya, bro. Real talk. Yeah.
If you're at that like Ron white
level where you know what I mean?
I know one has a plain crazy. That's
what I'm saying. Like if you're
there and I got an idea. That makes
sense. Hey, we got a book, Ron White.
Oh, he's the big guy to get them
on here and we got to talk about,
we got to Cadillac to talk here.
Doesn't he live in Florida or the
south somewhere? He has a Texas place,
but he's in La a lot. God, he's so fine.
You just need them to do a sales pitch
on why we should get a plane. Okay.
All right. Great idea. Thanks. I love
her. I'm like, thanks Ron in advance.
All right.
Um, and also we, yeah, I mean
I'm still upset about it. We
watched the Michael Jackson. Yeah.
We need to actually, we're
going to do this, I think,
think,
um,
this would be a great conversation
to have with our very own Josh.
Oh, the expert in creep salad.
Yeah. Sad. Dude. Why don't we,
should we stop down for a moment?
Why am each we'll be right back and we
are back and this is one of the most
exciting
times that we have doing this podcast.
We get to bring in a hilarious comedian,
a good friend and a questionable person.
It is Josh Potter.
Ooh, it's good. Right? I like that.
I like it a lot,
Tanner, for making that tanks. Tanner,
you really affect the lady's Josh.
I guess so. I have some sort
of effect, I guess. Right?
I guess any effects is goods and nun.
That's true. Uh, their effects
on me so far have been the same.
And that is no effect.
So we're still a no.
Recently I have, I have
put some reps in. Yup.
Sort of some research, if
you will, to find, you know,
to keep finding the bottom of this
mystery. And a, I did, you know,
I started at the bottom and
now we're here and so far,
you know, I've gathered some research.
I think I need to have like a,
a brain orgasm first.
You know what I'm saying?
Like a connection with somebody, you
mean? Yeah, because I drift away.
Maybe when you're on that,
what is that?
Oh,
that's my bedroom.
That's where I bring girls to come.
Do you like it?
Don't like I had a girl
not liked it recently.
She said she would get
my going to die here.
She was cold and that she would let me
tell you. I mean, why don't you describe,
let me break it down. Describe it.
Describe it. Well listen. Hey, it's clean.
So that's wonderful. You're already
a step ahead. I don't own any things,
so there's no way to make it messy.
So it's just like a bed in
a corner and there's, um,
I've been candles and you
have a candle. It, hey,
that's a for effort and that's my weed
next to it. And that's your weed. Good.
I mean, look, it's sparse,
but I liked that it's clean and I liked
that you even have a frame work that was
there when I got there, so. Oh really?
I was really pumped about that.
I've never had one of those before.
I've slept on an air mattress.
I slept on a regular mattress lay
sleeping on. Now that's a tempurpedic dog.
It's not as good as the sot
vote, but it's a, you know, I, I
immediately, yeah. What are you
doing here? I mean, I'll take,
I'll take a new mattress for a, sure. That
suitcase. That's a suitcase, by the way.
I see that. And then what's draped over
the headboard? Those headphones? Oh no,
that's just the blinds from
the, Oh, I tell you, number one,
what's wrong is that his bed is pushed
against the cold windows. I like,
of course you do. But any woman who's
laying nude in your bed or semi-closed,
it's fucking cold.
You're not supposed to sleep next
to them as a total lunatic with,
I know he's a cockroach.
They complained also that I like.
I don't have enough like
pillows or something. Well,
how many pills he, I have one.
That's all. I've only one head weight.
One pillow. Why you can you see?
What about for the chick that comes over?
I get one from a couch or something,
you know? No, no, no. She can't sleep on a
pillow. Tells a woman. This
is not going to be, well,
I think experience into pillows.
Presumptuous like human
sleep on two pillows.
You deserve to pillows.
Yeah.
God. Blue Band. Do you sleep on two
pillows? Yeah. I'm not a psycho.
That's a psycho move. I have your
head, your badge at f four pillows.
It's more that I don't even have
four of anything in there. No,
you should get four pillows. I have.
I don't have even for blankets.
Two for you to, for the lady that's not
going to live long after she lives there.
Okay. Let me ask you this. What's with
the medieval, the medieval tapestry.
That's a buffalo hills. That's
Buffalo. Bill's helmet. What? Okay.
That needs to go serial killer.
Now this looks,
it looks like he's got a medieval
combat tapestry. Buffalo bills,
a blanket that I got from a couch now
that's take that off. That this terrible.
Then I don't have any blankets like a
dog blanket. You should get you one.
Let's get you a different
style blanket, you know? Yeah.
That's not a bedroom blanket and that's
just some clutter at the end of my bed.
I'm sorry. That's fine. It's actually
pretty bare. And that's how I live, dude.
I that suitcase, I put that down
the day I moved in, that's where
it stays. It's part, it's
like my nightstand, the
nightstand, the nightstand,
the nightstand. That's what I had to
search with the suitcase does. No, no,
I get it. But I mean, you know, you're
not a freshman in college, right?
So yeah. But I mean like, I guess
here's the thing, like for real,
I always think the next day they're going
to throw me out of these places. Why?
You know what I mean? I Dunno. I've
lived in so many different apartment.
I've been here now for a while, right?
Yeah. Yeah. It's been, this is a little,
maybe one of the longest departments
I've ever lived in in my whole life,
so that's why it's like,
can you take him Jesus Christ and take,
take it until the way Ikea.
Yeah, somewhere and gets them.
Let's go shopping for furniture.
I need help.
I just want to get you some pillows.
A blend of different blanket.
I'll tell you another thing that they,
that the thing hang on the
wall while they, yeah, that's
where I was going to get.
They said that. That's weird. I don't
have anything on the wall. Zero.
It's all bare. Yeah. He's cause
he's living like he's a transient.
I'd be kicked out. Why do you think you're
going to get kicked out at any moment?
Is that a real threat?
Never been kicked out of her apartment,
but I've had to move at a rapid
pace a lot and then like you know,
you on the road, sometimes you
want to have an apartment. Yeah.
You're just kind of live in
other people's departments.
Do you think he'll stay here
for awhile and I want to,
I hope I stay here for a long time.
The bare walls not good. No Shit.
What do I get? Like, oh,
so I should get like a Jim Kelly poster
or something a way football player.
No, boom. Now we need just like,
let's just go get you a ladder
football player like ray Lewis or
maybe like a, you know, whales
jumping out of the water. Like A,
I like a neon Miller lite side.
[inaudible]
we have to squint your eyes
and the image pops out.
Well where would you
rather spend an evening?
In my bedroom or in the
now vacant Neverland ranch.
So yeah,
we were getting on a topic that,
I mean like if he want to listen
to Michael Jackson's music,
don't watch that documentary cause it's
so hard to go back to loving him after
all that.
I mean the part that makes me the craziest
is that he wasn't trying to conceal
the fact that he was a PDO file is your
dad says yes. There was no concealing it.
Like in the 80s. He, he paraded his,
his boys around out in the open end.
He did that and we all were complicit.
Everybody was like,
Emmanuel Lewis is your date
to the grammys? Cool. No
problem. Yeah, he likes kids.
That's a big guy.
And Jay Leno would make a joke at night
being like a kid's pants are half off.
And then, uh, everyone would
laugh and we'd all clap.
And then we listened to thriller and
that would be that he's the ultimate,
he was the ultimate,
like we've seen this with people
that are talented where we, um,
the talent pollutes our mind
into excusing certain behavior.
It's a hall pass.
He is the ultimate talent and name where
he was so famous and so talented that
we were like, he fucks. But I mean,
have you seen thriller? Like, yeah,
it was basically,
yeah.
That's what the sentiment that
was going to be weird with kids,
but boil them in a studio and it makes
mad really mean off the wall was a pretty
perfect at all.
Have you seen that moonwalk?
Touch my kid? You know, Daniel, by
the way, in that documentary, if they,
uh, if the parents were my
parents and they were like,
they were like a, hey, you know, sorry,
we've been separating from your
child so much. Uh, we just need,
we want you to have the nicest hotel
suite. My mom would have been like, yeah,
you can fuck him to
a hotel suite.
That'd be dope. Yeah. I
would totally be like,
just do whatever you want. Actually,
I think my mom would be the,
she would've been,
I would've been like so pissed at her.
She would have been like, you can't go
hang out with Michael Jack. I'd be like,
fuck you mom.
And then I would like go listen to Michael
Jackson in my room and turn the music
up real loud.
It would be because
Mommy said we're going to fuck.
And that she'd be like,
what's a disturbing doc?
What am I disturbing to me is that the
parents are still recounting the events
with Michael fondly. Like, and then we
got to fly first class all the way back,
the glimmer in their eye and talk
about it. It's sickening. Yeah.
There's still recalling it like
it was just a pleasant tail.
Nothing bad happened in that
situation again. They'd be like, yeah,
I think it all turned out fine. It's
worth it. We got to ride in a limousine,
Wade Robson's mom seemed
unfazed and it's like, well,
my son became a dancing prodigy.
Yeah, so she's like, how bad was it?
The way she makes sense.
That's the way she looks at her face.
It's me now are they all were like, it was
really an interesting house. Oh my God.
They went,
I wanted to bring up the house actually
because of this for sale right now.
Do you know that Neverland
ranch is for sale?
Besides do you want to be in on this
jet? Okay. What's the numbers? Well,
I want you,
because it went on sale initially in
2015 and it was worth $100 million guy am
now since this documentary's.
Yeah. Let's talk about the barn.
The value has dropped. Sig Nicholas. Okay.
Where do you think it's at right now?
To him? That's 500,000 came out. Yes.
Really?
Yes.
Well also the prelude to this
coming out, you know in, yeah,
people talk cause you
were saying you know this,
is this going to change the way you said
there was a lot of hype on this before
it came out.
So in the wake of that,
where do you think it shows up in the
mind thing to the nun sexual abuser.
It's probably a turnoff,
but I think to somebody that
celebrates um, pdf files,
like my dad,
it's a pdf file hall of fame.
He's covered in just, yeah, that Shit's
Canton. If you're, you're a pedophile.
And I was talking about it before.
We guessed the number that one of the
guys was talking about all the rooms he
went to Aa.
That's another thing he's
going to think I think lower than the
value of your more details in here.
And we did it here. Whereas before, if
like if you didn't know any of this stuff,
you'd be like,
I want to have this Michael Jackson House
to remembered honor Michael Jackson.
Now you'd be like,
we got to tear this shit apart man.
Which was like a murder for me.
Let me preface this by saying I had lunch
one time at the Charles Manson murder
house right now and I want to get
to that in a moment for his guests.
You're fit to be cleaned.
I was counted land.
Hold on more early on is discounted
land and significantly so it's child sex
land. This was priced at 100 million. Who?
I would say injured went down to 70
I'm going to go low or I'm going to go
70 25 million to him.
You are in the department.
You're kidding.
Dropped 70% it is now
listed at $31 million.
Wow.
I don't think it's going to go up
now. You mentioned that it, is it just
bank? Nobody owns it. I had to know.
I don't know who the broker is.
Have you made a Ferris wheel?
The cotton candy machine.
The monkeys played and this is,
what do you think he was
like that all the time.
Do you think he talked like that? Like,
cause you know he was like, you know,
he'd have to like, it's
ignorant. Ignorant on that.
Do you think behinds you'd be like
your Shit's off key. Yes. Yes,
yes.
I think he put on that bullshit total.
This is gentle and I lacked children's.
How did he get his,
how did he get a skin lighter?
No, that's all surgeries and she,
when you have that much
money you can do anything.
He made his daughter in a lab
and she's a gorgeous, gorgeous,
probably started with his ass
hole and then he was like,
she bleached asshole I think. So
He's like, I'm going for this,
lifted it up, showing it to the
doctors. No, take a closer look.
And then they were like, oh
yeah, that is pretty white.
And then there was a point
where he was perfect.
I would say when he came out and
thriller, he really looked, has knows.
Is it a good place? He was cute,
like off the wall. A little rough.
But that's the Thrillist started
plastic surgery. If he had,
if he hadn't pushed it past that he,
yeah, it would have been like, oh,
this guy had a little work done. But he,
and then he just kept going like that.
Do have plastic surgery.
He became probably addicted to it.
Total body dysmorphia
for sure. But you, Brent,
you've mentioned the Charles
Manson that you went to visit.
I had lunch one time at the clo drive
and I spoke to the gentleman that
purchased it and he said, well, yeah,
that murder land is discounted land.
So he got it at almost half price.
It was a tear down exact.
He tore it down and he built
this completely garish nuns.
It was multiple waterfalls
and Elvis Presley Room.
The guy is a total but is not a,
this is a common thing. Jon Benet Ramsey,
his house has been for sale forever.
That they had to change the
fucking street name. Oh, J house.
So the coalition didn't even kill
her there. That's right. Yeah.
Those apartments still function. I bet
some of lives in that fucking unit. Yeah.
I believe in that fucking go hook it up.
I got a bed in a suitcase.
I can move into there, but uh, I got
a lease and a key, the question is,
would you rather live in a home
where a terrible murders occurred?
Yeah. Or the Neverland ranch. Murder.
Murder. All everyone say murder.
Why? Well, what is the
ultimate eat the worst.
Evil is definitely what Michael was doing.
There's nothing more evil and
distinction where my uncle,
but I'm thinking in terms of aftermath,
you know like in,
in terms of living in a place,
the murder they splayed open,
their guts are everywhere. There was
blood everywhere. Sure you clean it.
But that happened. A person was inside
out in the home. They don't, don't care.
Not compared to care to a kid. Yeah, but
there's nothing, I mean there's nothing.
I rather bathed in the blood of a hundred
slaughtered women even step into a
room where something happened to uh, wow.
Well, Manson and the Sharon Tate murders,
she was seven months pregnant. They cut
open, her pregnant belly took her baby.
I wouldn't live in, I'm saying I would
live in the Manson house over Neverland.
Amy [inaudible] is terrible. I
mean, look man, even in prison,
inmates have a code that
what Michael was doing is
I would have signed up to watch the
little, do you think are Kelly's here?
If our Kelly does go to prison,
you think they fucked him up where
they're like they fuck with him.
They won't put him in the general, he'll
be in protective custody. But he also,
there's a term for it
and I forget what it,
cause I've seen it in one of these
shows that he actually targeted women
entering their sexual a 14,
15 year.
That's what I mean. So the prisoners will
be more because our Kelly's brother, uh,
in this documentary about
r Kelly for instance,
if we can shift gears for a moment.
His brother creeps is involved in the
documentary and he's actually in prison
from the documentary.
He is good. Yes. He's,
he's interviewed from prison now
are Kelly has a couple brothers.
He's got a brother Kerry who's younger.
Those are right there. He's there.
What I do, man, he, yes.
And then what he did was he'd be like
singing about sex and fucking and shit.
And then he'd go, I'm going to do
a church song. And everyone's like,
it's forgiven. You know what I
mean? Well, same with Michael,
wasn't he like you got to save the world.
It's got to make the world a better place,
our than,
and you are not alone by the way. It's
a, it's a, it's always the and huge.
Yeah. Our Kelly wrote that nailed
years ago. We play years ago.
Peter King, I think that's
his name, right? I am the
only guy with the right was,
this was right after Mike died and
I think this guy's still in
office. Uh, 11 uh, but he,
The v celebration of Michael
as being ridiculous like this.
Hi, this is Congress from pitching
and a yesterday I'm watching tools.
What did your wife Prays and One
Chore and Really Reminded me Of,
do you have a great men and women who
sacrificed so much for our country?
People fighting in Iraq and Afghanistan
today? Yup. Cops, firefighters, teachers,
none of whom really get much in the last,
I don't know how long now this lowlife
Michael Jackson space picture is all over
the newspapers, television, radio.
So we hear about as Michael Jackson
and let's knock out the psychobabble.
This guy was a carver,
Arkansas Child restaurant header file.
And to be giving this much
coverage to him day in and day out.
What does it say about us and our country?
Well, here's the deal. He
must be really mad today.
Oh man, this guy's probably
play playing this deal. Look,
I know it takes on, this is the only
correct opinion on all of this. Oh, sure.
Skype. It came into my head
immediately, right? No. Yeah.
The next morning I woke up.
I remember that guy we
played. Yeah, this is the guy.
This is the right fucking
way to think about this whole
thing. Play the rest. Yes.
Correct. No one wants to stand up and
say, that's right. Michael Jackson. Yeah.
He died. He had some talent and you're
fine because people dying every day.
There's men and women
dying say in Afghanistan,
let's give them the credit they charge.
I really think the media
has disgraced himself.
I think of too many people in public life.
I made fools of themselves by
talking about Michael Jackson's.
If you some kind of hero,
there's nothing good about this.
Maybe a good CEO did some dancing.
You let your child
never may have been a good thing and
dance. Dancing. Oh by the way, I want,
I just want to take this moment to thank
you for taking me on the road and never
making me stimulate your nipples.
You're welcome or spread. That was my,
that was the other one. See
your a turn me off. Yeah. Yeah.
I just hope I don't get old and
gross and kicked off tour. Yeah,
but are the answer.
Did some dancing.
But I wanted to show you our Kelly's
brother cause he was in prison and he is
the only one coming to his
brother's aid in this documentary.
Yeah. I haven't seen the art Kelly Doc. I
can't. Why can't, there's a Jetta goodbye.
Oh Geez. A commercial
jet. Sure. Younger women.
You have people who have
fantasies about different things.
I like hold your women. Okay. Figure.
Nope.
That's just a preference.
It's a preference. Everyone
has preferences. It's true.
So what is the big deal?
What's the big issue with my brother?
Hmm.
Can Dare to answer. Yeah. We mean,
I think for people who,
I
don't know,
those people who are listening or
watching who don't know about the r Kelly
details. Really? You don't think so for
sure. It's, I mean, with the documentary,
I thought, no way the people
have the same amount of this,
this story has the same amount of
exposure as Michael Jackson in a way.
That's a good point. And uh, I think
though it's, it is in the news right now.
Michael have, Nadia has picked
up another charge for our Kelly,
so he is being prosecuted again in
the wake of this documentary. Yeah.
But his brother,
uh,
his other brother Carey was not so ride
or die with r Kelly because r Kelly
approached him about taking the fall
for the pee pee tape being like,
oh,
tell him it was you in there.
Well, you just turning on your
radio. We're talking to Carrie Kelly,
r Kelly's younger brother. You did a
body double for your big brother Robert.
You body's calling and things kind of
turned a little ugly when this whole child
molestation thing came into play.
People were trying to say was you,
his attorney said that it was me and a
video saying, hey, that was the argument.
He never came forth and said, hey, you
know what y'all are hearing is not true.
Yo, did we have another tape
of a tire? More restaurant?
Do we have another type of a Bruce? I
can't remember. Oh yeah, that's the third.
Yeah.
Can you play that one?
This is Bruce's reaction to his brother
not liking the idea of being not only
the body double in music videos, but in
his sex tape as well. For what he does.
Robert simply ask Carrie
to tell the truth,
do a deposition with his attorney stat.
The things that he was saying
was not true. And he said,
if you do this deposition
with my attorneys,
I will give you $100,000 in
a one record contract deal.
I never understand that
it's wrong causality.
If you could have been rich,
I never understand.
So he's like, I can't say like
turn that idiot. He's like,
hold on million down
to the recognize shit.
Put My fucking name on that deposition.
Oh my God. So, um, so Bruce,
what's he in jail for? Well,
he's been in there for,
I had to write down his charges.
Nothing wild by the way.
Nothing like r Kelly has ever done. Yeah.
For the record it's just burglary. Oh,
things like that.
Like a drug possession and okay.
And stuff like a no violent
crimes unless you, uh,
consider basically like for people
that aren't well informed on the arc,
how the scandal that he like,
part of it is that he's
been keeping women, uh,
basically as sex slaves.
Oh yeah.
Like locked up in homes with like no cell
for to that because he's been allowed
so much leeway in the past.
He was just kind of doing things like
Michael Jackson where he was bringing
younger women around and things
like that. People just thought, oh,
he likes the younger one and
people help facilitate that.
He married Aaliyah when she was 15. Yeah.
That was so, and it's also the thing too,
it's like prodigies that
they build, right? Yeah.
It's like Wade Robson has turned
into an international dance,
Super Mega Star choreograph for dance.
You know that I did not know that the
way the Australian boy that could, yeah.
Yeah. He, he's uh, he was the
choreographer for like Brittany Spears.
That right guys is that they
say,
what did I say?
I want to be a comedian more than I want
to be anything in the fucking world.
I want it so fucking bad.
And if you,
if you make me go back in time and you
told me like this is what you do it,
but you're going to be Sebastian.
I don't know that I would've said no,
take the deal.
Really.
You would just have your childhood robbed
from you and now you're doing Madison
Square Garden, right? There's
cause. Think about this.
I said this to somebody and
they think I'm a monster.
There are so many children that are
victims of terrible crimes like this,
that are in a fucking alleyway
or a fucking dumpster behind it.
You know what I'm saying?
Like terrible circumstance.
These kids got immune park at least right?
Free Popcorn.
She got to see screeners a fucking
Bambi before that came out probably in,
I don't know if I can get onboard
with this lie not taking jobs.
Obviously all of its pair. Wait a minute,
you are a comedian, you know I want,
you know what I mean?
Like I and I'm very happy to be a
comedian but that's my point. Like I,
my desire is so much and it's like how
much do you love dance and dude like is
it wasn't what I would like to ask them
that question. Was it worth it? Yeah.
Being Michael's sex slave as a child.
Oh my God,
we could bring Sebastian and on this
John here another phone quote from
our Kelly's brother. By the way,
me and my brothers, we all have our
ways with our girls were very jealous.
We don't want our girls
doing certain things.
You're not going to see our
girls talking to too many people.
That's just the way we are.
Cause he was keeping them behind closed
doors and shit and like he was keeping
them safe, keeping them clearly really
his ride or die. This brother. Yeah man.
He is, well, could you imagine being
in jail for all these petty things?
He's probably in there for a, for
a quite a few, few years, you know,
after amounting so many crimes and his
other brother gets this other opportunity,
he's just sitting there and this
felt like, shit, what the fuck?
I would love to fucking do that.
You know what I'm saying?
I wonder what you would be willing to
do right now. Other things you want.
This is interesting.
[inaudible]
it's not about what I would be
willing to do to anyone else.
It's like what I would be willing
to have it. I'm talking to me.
That's what I'm saying.
I would degrade myself to levels of which
are inconceivable to achieve my goals.
Yeah. I mean, I haven't
sold my soul at this point.
I mean like, I don't know. Let's
say a big time promoter. Yeah.
Um, he's like, you know, I,
I can hook up any gig and
I'll have a plan for you.
We were going to do is we're
going to start off in these clubs.
It's going to be this and then
theaters and it's a three year plan.
You're going to make millions
dollars. You're going to
sell all these tickets. Uh,
kind of my house at first thing's first
hands behind your back, mouth open.
I'm dipping my balls. In your mind.
Who is this guy? First of all?
Is it he's a Michael Jackson guys. A
little creepy. He's a little weird.
He's a heavier set man. Older. It
doesn't smell. Is it a try it out guy?
Kind of like the try it out guy. Yeah,
you have to do the try it out guy.
You're his sex slave.
But the end game is something
inconceivably successful
or it's Harry or we asked
to do Terry's butt plug every day,
I think. No, I think try it out.
Just the plot plug and try it out.
Guy. That guy is, I have to eat.
Try it out as you can come every day.
He lays it out for you.
He tells you the deal,
you know you got gotta you got to bend
over showing her ass whole lot. Yeah.
And he wants, you know,
now what if I'm you,
you said I have to make
him calm every day.
Do I have to make him calm or do
I have to at least try to, no,
you have to mention he doesn't come.
I and I put in all the effort and I'm
really just firing on all cylinders and
I'm giving them everything.
I got the whole kitchen
sink and everything and he
doesn't come and I still lose
out. You can make them come though
achievable goal. Is it okay.
Cause that's the only thing that would
concern me is if I was put into the
situation and I couldn't succeed in my,
uh,
end of the responsibilities.
Do you know what I mean?
Then he takes it away from me.
Then I wouldn't have liked to
put myself in that kind of a,
how many days do I have to make
them come? Like, is that expressive?
It's a deal with the devil. Oh,
so it's like if forever ever,
I don't know if I could do, here's
why. No, no, no. Let's do forever.
Only because when you molest children,
yes. Ruins them for their whole life.
I still have the psychological damage,
not as an adult. It's a little more, well,
can you mess with children that way you
destroy their soul for the rest of their
lives,
right?
The rest of his life be destroyed.
Let's have a time limit
though to see if this works.
I don't know that I could do rest
of my life. I think I could put a,
let's say there's a six round through.
Well, you mentioned the three year.
It's a three year progression to success.
Once I hit the mountain top,
I get to stop you. How it'd be
like, all right. You know, sniff,
sniff. No, no, no.
Let's do this way.
Let's do an actual deal with the devil.
So he gets successful and
then in the afterlife thing,
there is one every day he has to
suck the train. See land stuff.
I'm talking about a real
fucking pitch where the guy,
I am giving you my pitch pitch. The
guy says, come over to my house.
Suck my balls and eat my ass every day.
I'm going to fuck you and all your holes
and then I'll give you gifts. I look,
try to negotiate some of it down. I'd
be like, everyday it's tough. I'm going,
I got stuff. So then he says in the
fuck area. Okay, well then I'd be like,
can we do three days a week? And
we do, you know, get out of here.
Do you want it fine? Yes, I'll, I'll do
every day. We'll see how long we know.
What did you really do it?
You think you would really do it for that?
I don't know man. I really think I'd
think about it. I really do. I don't.
First Time, the first time he comes
all over your face, you're like,
and you go like to wash off and he hands
you the envelopes got like eight grand
in it. He's like, yeah, your job.
I would feel funny that he's like,
you're playing the Improv this week.
I would feel discussing with myself,
but it doesn't it. I would feel
happy at the end. End result.
I already hate myself, so that's
not going to like decrease really.
Do you know what I'm saying? Like so
much therapy. I just don't think like,
I think it would be out to, I'd call
my friend and be like, you know,
I had to suck this fat old man's thick.
It was terrible. I mean it was everything.
He was as awful as you think it is.
But you threw me an envelope of
a crane and I've got a fucking,
I'm doing all the improv snatch, so, so
I think other comics would it be like,
well shit. All right, you really, you
really think you would do that though?
I think I might think about
it. That's all I, I don't,
I've never been put in there. What if he
started really the way that you put it,
like where you're like, and you're
doing theaters. I'd be like,
am I selling all these tickets
because I sucked a dick?
Then that's all it takes then fine.
Now what if he really started hurting your
ass hole? That's going to hurt. I mean,
that's key, but you're selling
more tickets, more pain,
more game, baby, let's go.
You know? I mean Shit,
I see his point though.
It's hard to sell tickets and
to become something in this.
If I just had to suck a dick,
then I would do it the way that I,
I when I pointed it out. Yeah.
Speaking of tickets, where's your show?
March 22nd at the Hollywood improv lab.
I will suck all your dicks.
Buy Tickets. 10:00 PM show, 10:00 PM show,
line up in the back after and
uh, we'll get it going. You know,
you're putting that out there.
There they have a right to get their dick
suck now. Okay. Some dicks. All right.
All right, good. Um, I would
rather get buck pounded than suck.
Suck dicks to Jesus and saying,
think it tastes people.
Oh wait, no. I would rather,
I would rather have a dick
in my ass then in my mouth.
Wow.
To really think about it to my mouth.
No, no, no. Think about it. But
really think about it for one minute.
Your ass is a nightmare. All Ready?
Yeah. Here's the thing. Taking it.
Yeah, I agree. I'll do.
Then you have to taste it.
You're going to fucking have
to scope and be like, ah,
and you're going to be like, it's
your fucking teeth and shit face babe.
Someone's fucking your face and asshole
where your poop comes out. Who Cares?
I agree. I'm with Josh on
this thing 100% all right.
Time to think about it though. Yeah. You
really want them in your beard and stuff.
Think it tastes it all day. You can't
get that taste out. You don't like,
you don't even eat certain foods.
Right. So trail, I don't like olives.
Yeah.
And I did like all is all
in your beard on your eyes?
Depending who's Dicky tastes.
It'd be like an dog.
It'd be like a big holiday and his nuts
could stink real bad. Oh they will? Yeah.
This guy,
this promoter guy I'd rather do in this
class because then you can just hear
you're bucking heel shit.
All the Jews out of Utah Right about
definitely finishing in your asshole.
Yeah. But I mean, I was
like, and he's like, aids
comes in your butt. And then I'd be like,
Oh God, you know, it's tough to sit down,
but I'd rather that than
be like, yeah, we're like,
the rest of the fucking day he tastes
it and every time he's in here Tommy,
I don't want that. And he's like, Oh God,
it keeps the of your butt. But good news.
You're playing Talia Hall of Chicago
so it's all sold out. I'd be like,
not my stomach.
I had some other nightmares I
wanted to bring up. If we have time,
I don't know how much, I don't
know. He may not. We're running out,
we'll have to shelve it.
But there is one other gentleman I'll end
on that is from a band called the lost
profits to ban. I listened to as a
child, as a teenager I should say.
And they weren't very popular at all.
That shit man right there.
He was Michael Jackson on
steroids but had no fame and no,
nobody helping him in this regard.
And he was not like,
as you noticed that these guys are
like all elaborate in their schemes and
everything like that.
This guy was not at all.
So he was pretty easy
to catch an a monster.
We got out of the realm pretty quickly.
What happened to him was the British
version of the NSA went to hack his
computer because there was rumor that he
had child pornography on it. Oh Jesus.
Crowl and uh,
they didn't take long to crack it because
his password turned out to just be I
fuck kids. What? That was
his password to his computer.
Could you imagine being those,
that crack team of detectives and you,
do you think it took them long or do
you think they sat there and were like,
I'm just gonna try a couple of things
here real quick and just put in a couple
of last words. Guess number one.
Yeah. He's like, the guy did one, two,
three and he's like, no, that didn't
work. Let me try my second idea.
And he figured it out pretty quick,
but this guy's in jail.
So you listened to his music? I had
t shirts. I had, I was doing my,
I was given to the band and it, it was,
it wasn't like I didn't give a fuck.
I'll never listen to the band again,
like it wasn't that prevalent
in my life that I was like,
I'm going to miss he locked up
right now. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's fucking in jail for
this guy on a plane, Tom,
to go back to our first discussion. Okay.
This guy's walking past me now and I go,
could I love him? Here's the number. What
do you think the turn off his hair? Yeah.
I'd be like the hairs too complicated.
He's got teeth to co two intro.
I was going to say the
earrings too complicated
and I don't like carrying your angel hair.
It's too dark. It doesn't match. Yeah.
Sorry about that.
About those lobes wear earrings.
I don't think so, but he's
too, he's too complicated.
That's what I would say. Yeah.
He was in like an emo band. Yeah. Why?
I get a cold cold eyes
for sure, man. Well, yeah,
he's going to jail in that picture. Yeah.
It was probably like, you know what,
I'm fucked.
Yeah. I saw kids is definitely,
what a terrible password.
Thanks Josh. Can we run this real
quick? This? Yeah, we have time. Yeah.
Let's run this script. So what is this?
Well, this, I have here also like, uh,
we have talking sex tapes and
all kinds of celebrity, uh,
musicians that are into wacky, wild
stuff. This one's a little more fun.
It has nothing to do with children. It's
just a fun guy, you know, shut with Barry.
Barry Barry, you know my
cousin. It's your cousin Marvin.
Marvin Berry. Yeah. Yeah.
That this is a,
this is credited with being the pioneer
of Brock and was like the king of rock
and roll. Yeah. He's the
man. Well, he also, uh,
enjoyed filming women that he
would have sex with and uh,
doing a number of demeaning
things to them. And in fact,
he has a sex tape somewhere in this world,
but because of the time of that,
it was in like the sixties or
seventies or whatever, you know,
we don't have it heavily distributed.
So what I've gone through
is the transcript of the
sex tape and I've delivered
it to you so we can reenact it today.
That's the role of Berry will be Tom
Secura and in the role of blonde,
white whore. Thank, we'll
be Christina P. Wow.
Will you read the salaried, the
stage directions? All right,
so I'll start at a table read and
the industry. Tom, this is it.
It's all you did for your soul, allegedly.
Of course. Yeah. Right? Yeah, he's Dad.
He didn't care. Yeah. All
right, ready? Uh, okay.
Do you have any tips for me that a ta at
a table read Europe near a white horse
with big, big tits and you're blonde
and white and whore. Okay. Alright,
here we go.
All right. [inaudible] are you
bathing? Yes. Got To get clean.
Yes, I do. You like to
stay clean, don't you? Yes,
I do.
You really do.
I'll give you something to
bathe. War. You know what?
You know that he stands up over her and
would give you something to bathe for.
See this here? Yeah. He's
wiggling his dick. He, yes.
Yeah. That's what you
bade where it is. Kiss it.
Kiss it again. Suck on it. You my girl.
Yes. You love me. Yes, very much.
No Bitch. You do. I do.
Well, you really love me.
He begins pissing on her face.
She Gaffes surprised. I
really, I love you. Yeah.
Put your hands down by your das.
Take it.
She continues gasping as he
continues to Piss. Take it. Take it.
Take over your mouth. Open your mouth,
the sound of Piss, gurgling in her mouth,
and then Barry unleashes a loud,
long parts. You could smell my farts.
Piss on you. That's what I'm doing.
Pissing all over you. You love me.
Tell me you love me. I love you.
All right then drink my piss.
Drink my piss. Chuck grabs a towel
and hands it to her. Dry myself off.
Clean yourself off. How's that piss
taste? Bitter. All right. All right.
All right. Tastes better. Doesn't
it? Salty. Yeah, I know. Yes.
You dragged my pis. Yes I
did. Yes. Suck. They suck it.
She is sucking and gasping and grunting
as if in pain. Can you clean yourself?
Clean the piss out of gas portion of it.
A little baby wasn't mad baby.
Did I piss in your eyes? Yes.
Without pissing your eyes. I'm sorry.
There's Piss all over your neck and
your head, but you love me. I love you.
I won't. I won't betray you. I
won't betray. You have a believer.
He leans in to kiss her, then stops
immediately. I can't kiss you.
Smells like piss. I know. I'm sorry.
Clean yourself off. Take a shower.
He walks out of the tub as she
turns on the Faucet to clean herself
and saying, wow, that
was really good stuff.
It was nice.
We should send that one off for
like Chuck Berry and the bio page.
Is that what it's like for the movies?
When you guys do your table
reads exactly like that.
I kind of want to send that to a
couple of directors. Yeah, you could.
I mean,
could play some
abusive. Yeah. Yeah. He, oh,
abusive guy. A number one God,
I would love to play something like that.
What do you mean?
That's perfect for you? So what
I'm saying, it's an instant family.
You're a jerk in that movie. Yeah. But I
mean he wasn't pissing in Fart on girls.
That mean? Is that what you took into
the role in your mind? You're like, okay,
I'm showing the behind
the scenes chuck berry.
Um, we, uh, this was great.
Thank you. As always. Josh,
thanks for having me. I hope I see
everyone. March 22nd Hollywood improv lab.
10:00 PM get your tickets.
Yeah. Yeah. Your mom's house.
We'll be right back and we are back.
Everyone peed and farted and eight and
we are back now with one of our all time
faves. Um, a real country singer.
It is wheeler Walker Jr. Thank you very
much. [inaudible] guys. I love dailer.
The new place is fucking killer.
Thanks man. Steakhouse vibes studio.
What'd you call the studio
jeans? Yes. Inside Studio G.
I liked how you didn't model it after
studio g. You actually can put shit up.
Yeah, that's right. It's not just an
empty conference room. That's right.
That's right. You know, I didn't,
I didn't really notice that your right
wheeler that he just doesn't even bother
decorating it.
Oh,
he didn't give a shit that he thinks
people are just going to fucking look at
him. Yeah, he's right. Right
before he snap somebody's neck.
And we hope one day he tells us where the
bodies are. But Garth is a really, he,
we were talking about creeper musicians,
you know, we didn't talk about, yeah,
we didn't have, um, I was
trying to think of his name
and uh, Jerry Lee Lewis. Yes.
He married her 13 year old 18 year olds.
Nice.
That's like pedophilia,
an incest. And then Elvis,
I mean she was a fucking teenager,
but the room,
I think the story that he tried to tell
was he met her when she was 15 and then
they get married at like 19 or
whatever the legal, I waited,
I waited finally. I mean does it,
it not get what he wants, you know,
but we were just talking about the Chuck
Berry thing. Man, I love Chuck Berry,
but the day he died,
um,
you tweeted the p video and I was kind
of bombed like fucking Chuck Berry, man.
It was crazy.
And that I was alive at the same time and
I started getting bummed out about it.
And once you see him pissing on white
women and kind of, you know, just kind of,
and you can bring your base like,
you know what, I'll be, I'll be fine.
So it helps you. I helped you grieve
in a way. Do you have no idea?
But there was no,
I grieved for about half a second until
I saw him fucking pissing off women.
I'm gonna, you know, world's
probably better off if I do
love him. His music. Yeah.
Yeah. Well that's, we we're
talking about that weighing the,
the fame and the talent against doing
something horrible. Yeah. I mean it's,
it's strange too, because we were
talking about before, it's like,
do I let my life, am I allowed to listen
to thriller now? Like, how's it going?
You know? But you definitely are
allowed, but it's like, does it play,
does it play a game in your mind?
Having listened to us since I
watched that thing, which by the way,
and I don't want to start controversy,
I think he's guilty and the doc I saw,
but I just don't want to get myself in
trouble here and start, you know? Yeah.
You know, I'm not the judge and jury.
Right. But there was a lot of evidence,
you know, once I hear about the
actual blood and the anus, I'm like,
I think this guy did it. Yeah. And then
I'm like, but, but thrillers such a great,
it's not a bad note in the whole
thing. It's amazing. It's so difficult.
But it does make you wonder.
I mean,
now we're just in an era where we're
accepting that our heroes are pieces of
shit.
How many of our past heroes have been
pieces that we don't even know about or
even know about? I don't
see nothing wrong. Well, my,
my thing is just always assume they're
a piece, a piece of shit. I mean,
everybody who's talented, Amy,
I mean, you guys know, I mean,
you didn't get into comedy because like
you had your all your shit together and
I didn't start playing music cause
like, man, I got it all figured out.
Now I'm going to get, it was this guy was
covering up a lot of fucking shit. Yeah.
But not an island stuff. Right. I
mean, um, pedophilia, no violence,
no pedophilia. I've lived a pretty
clean life compared to, well the people,
you mean what's your big vice
though? You have a big vice. Um,
cause you don't really seem like
you're my, I guess my advice would,
would say fucking, but now
that I'm married, you know,
I didn't even know you were married.
Married. Yeah. I'm married with a kid.
That's what ww three my new records about
w three is named after my son Wheeler
Walker. The third. Oh my fucking
name man. Congratulations.
When I talk to people and Catch Ketchup,
I forget some of the details. Yeah. Wow.
So that's what the new record
is all about. Low Wheeler. Yeah.
He's basically retired. The pussy
king. You want? Yeah, I mean,
I mean he's done conquering all the walls.
Now I'm teaching him,
but that's like some of the new songs,
you know,
all the pussy you will slay telling him
about the new. Right, right. Was He,
he's going to get and training him. Yeah.
He's, he's Pussy King Jr and you know,
she's, my wife has, is she
has her own Instagram. She's
the Pussy Queen, you know?
Really? Yeah. God Damn. Wow.
I want to see some pics. Yeah,
we got to look her up. No, now
I'll take a soda Pussy Queen.
The pissy queen. How did, so
how'd you meet him? Shoot,
I was playing a Gig in Alabama and she
came back in the days when I was meeting
chicks after gigs and we, and I was
like, oh, I'll just banger and take off.
But I kept talking. I was like, fuck,
I want to talk to talk to her again.
You know what's her handle?
Is that it? No. Yeah, that's
her not as good. I that's,
I don't know who that is yet. Her,
what's her hand? Her Instagram handle.
It might be miss, Ms. Wheeler
Walker. I don't know. I forget.
I got off social media to tell you that
did, why I fucking over it. You know,
the main,
my main thing was like when I first
started out and I took over country music.
You guys saw it. Of course.
I was all, it was all about,
I felt like I was, I was, the new
guy was punching up. I love it.
And, but now that I'm bigger than these
fuckers, I just feel like it's, I'm bored.
It's like people, I make fun of
these new country shit holes.
There's all this news,
garbage pop country,
but I've figured them so I can get some
kind of punching down and these people
cry and complain to their
managers and Shit. She's like,
it's just not worth it anymore
than like now they're coming on.
They would go on my Instagram and try
to insult, insult back. I'm just like,
I don't have time for this shit. The point
was to get rid of Shitty pop country,
Florida, Georgia line, Florida. Georgia
line is still a lot bigger than me, but,
but the, all these new, the
Florida Georgia line wannabes,
they just don't have time to like insult
it. Cause Contra national man there,
they got new shitty artists
coming out of every 10 minutes.
It's like I can factory. Who
Do you hate right now? Um,
well there was this guy called, he's
still around, but that was a good,
the fire just, it didn't feel
right. It's like, why am I,
why am I shitting on this guy
that no one's even heard of?
The name was Mitchell 10 penny as a real
fucking name isn't really stupid named
Bi.
And um,
he had a song called bitches and I just
got pissed cause I had song called fuck
you bitch. Which I felt was emotional
song and that's a huge hit, Bucky,
that he just, so then he just took bit,
he's like, he's like literally just like,
I'm sick of bitches. I'm like,
that's not what my song was in.
And he like has a big label behind it and
was trying to pretend like it wasn't a
fee,
was like,
that's a whole nother thing saying I
hate bitches versus fuck the girl who
dumped me, I think fuck you bitch bitches
about a particular person. Yes, exactly.
I mean, I don't want to get
into an argument with this
dope about it, but it just,
but him on,
I was going down like I don't want to
wake up in the middle of the night and
just tweet at some random read and
write. Yeah. Yeah. Understandable.
And these aren't this,
I mean I've said it before.
I do think most country artists and fans,
you know, even though you know that,
do you mean football is so big in
the south and high school football?
I really think the majority
of country fans have CTE.
I think that's where this shit,
you don't listen to,
you don't listen to friends
in low places a hundred times.
Cause cause you're all there, you know
something's wrong. And these people,
and I think the artists have it too,
cause everyone I've talked to like yeah,
I'll meet these guys on
the screen somewhere,
fans and I'll talk to them like
something there. Yeah. You're like, what?
So what did you play? College ball
or, yeah, that's it. Yeah. They all,
I mean nowadays like Sam Hunt, who was
one of the big guys I went after, he was,
uh, a college QB. So I think my, my, my
theory checks out because these dudes,
I mean to, to like this kind of music, you
got to get hit in the head a lot. Yeah.
Yeah. I think you, I think
you solving real. Yeah, no,
I do. I swear to God. I mean,
when, if there's a, if you can fill
up Wrigley field. Yeah. With Florida,
Georgia line fans, that's a lot of, I
mean they all got car wrecks or something,
I don't know.
Right.
But even going to see Garth and hearing
friends in low places for the thousandth
time. I mean, do we have enough of
friends and little bright places? And I,
I've had off,
I've had it.
Yeah. I mean that was the thing.
And we talked about a little bit,
I think last time I was here,
which is people don't under like right
now because country music is basically
computers and bullshit and
stuff. That's crazy. That's,
that's found its way into country.
Yeah.
Cause I mean they're trying to do our
Kelly and there's going to be an art Kelly
of country. I guarantee you
somebody who's coming. Yeah.
I mean the stories I hear about
these artists, they're just,
these guys are fucking degenerates.
Um,
but like people don't understand
that when in the late eighties,
early nineties, like it was Dwight
Yoakam, Alan Jackson, good country,
ours and black and Clint black.
And then Garth came along.
He was the Florida Georgia line at the
time cause he was playing that real pop
shit. Yeah. All those guys
hated Garth and people.
Now I get why they get pissed when I
make fun of Garth but all but you got to
remember,
cause I'm older than these fucking dudes,
they at the time Garth was Florida,
Georgia line. You know, he was a guy.
I didn't realize that.
Yeah, because he was,
you hear it not like it's the so
slick and keep me going for pop radio.
Well its soul. I personally,
from what I've heard, cause
I watched part of that, um,
Notre Dame concert. Oh God. That was
all, yeah. And I, and I was like, okay,
where's the soul? And I,
and I, I'm not, listen,
I'm not an Aficionado of country music,
but when somebody sinks from
their fucking heart, you know,
you listened to Dolly Parton
singing Jolene or whatever you like,
that really grabs you
emotionally. But for him, there's,
I don't feel that from him
with authenticity. Yeah.
You did a lot of bullshit,
but would you, if you just
heard it on a blind taste test,
would you think that was country music?
Probably not. No. It's like pop. Yeah.
To me it's just like kind of almost
like just pop songs with me. Yeah.
And at that time,
him getting all that success kind of
made all the other guys try to sound like
Garth.
And I was trying to be the new Garth and
people like Alan Jackson were just I to,
I want pedal steel. I want to play country
music, you know? But anyway, fuck him.
He's fat,
he's fat.
He's the worst version
of the gummies fam, man.
Um, yeah. So speaking of, uh, old g,
by the way, how old wheeler?
Like being married with a kid,
I fucking love it, honestly. It's just,
it's like you don't always reminds me of,
which is kind of my dumb movie
references. Remember enough, Forrest Gump,
when he like got that thing in the mail
with the, that he'd like had had um,
put, he'd put a bunch of money on apple
stock before it, like got big and he just,
he just like Forrest Gump, just like
dope, get some thing in the mail.
Like he's like a billionaire. He's like,
oh, there's one less thing to worry about.
That's how I kind of feel
I got married. I'm done. Like, it's just
like pussy, one less thing to worry.
I don't have to do deal with it anymore.
The fucking texting and you know,
look going out on dates. I just hated
all that shit. How she feel about you,
you know, Torrin as this country artist
and you know, doing shows on the road
knows I'm going to,
I mean it's,
she knows what you guys know is that
I'm the most honest and cleanest guy out
there, so there ain't gonna
nothing to worry about, you know?
Yeah. So hold on one second. We've got to
stop one second. Well that was fun. Um,
thank you for the Burp. Introduction
to, yeah. Well, you know,
I just try to keep it real on the show.
Keep it true to who we are. You said it.
Sorry. Let's take a break. I was talking
about my wife had to whack off, so, yeah.
Yeah. I didn't want, he didn't want to do
it on the cameras. Oh, she's so electric.
You've met her on just like one of your
regular Gig and had gig gig outside of
immobile and you're like,
I'm just going to bang and leave.
And then I kept thinking about her and
then what, how, here's what happened.
There's a song on my new album, ww three.
I'll hold it up for the listeners. Yeah.
Um,
and uh,
this song called stilling sick of
fucking you, which is real. That's real.
Cause I'm, I'm so dumb. I didn't know.
I don't know what love is. You know,
this is my first love album and it just,
that's how I'm, and I'm admitting it.
I don't,
I just didn't know how fucking dumb,
I was like fucking this girl was cool
fucking her second. And it's like,
after 50 times is this love cause I just
still want to keep fucking her and that
is love. That's what I, I finished
and I got off the bed ago.
I could do that like a bunch of more
times, like even till I die. And I go,
that's probably what my parents were
telling me about when they met each other.
That's probably exactly what they
meant, but it's just like, but you know,
I like to say it in my own
way. So let's, I'll do a song.
What's Mama think it was Mama
Walker? Think of, oh, she loved it.
They all love her because she's normal.
I mean not normal to me.
And they love having a grandkid that
they hope won't ever hear my music. But
let me just now about almost
a year. He's a year old. Yeah.
So exciting. Now. Um, uh,
the three of us, you know,
really like to dissect g and m
a lot of his antics. You actually,
we're always on the lookout for new g,
uh,
footage and,
and material and that you
actually pointed out this twice.
You have a g alert.
What's it called?
Google alert and the alert for the
g alerts. Yeah, he put on hang.
That was so fucking ridiculous.
He did like his own trip.
You know that Bohemian rhapsody
moving? Yeah. That was like,
but can that guy be any fucking weirder?
Think they always say it. It's like, man,
he was so great. He seemed just like him.
I think it'd be just like the
dude's kind of w it's like,
is that really acting and some
impersonation. That's true. But anyway,
so Garth did this tribute
to the movie like freelance.
I don't think it's part of the promotion.
Did it on his own.
He just loves him and shot it with like
real like you know like the g live in
studio g's like fucking iPhone cameras.
This is like fucking film cameras and it
looks like he's ejaculate and the whole
fucking time he said,
you've never seen anybody,
I haven't seen this anybody to see
anything more than he loves queen.
And he starts kind of singing along and
moving his hands. You know, like, like he,
he gets so into the music that I,
like I said, I think he's wet himself.
You gotta tell me how to
set up my ga alerts. Yeah.
Oh God. Yeah. No, let's,
let's do the things that Freddie mercury
flamboyant entertainer from across the
water had in common was this kid.
And I'll cost the drafter wash.
Oh boy can secure as hell under the music.
I saw the courage.
He always goes a creepy rough,
still important. But wait, wait till he
plays a museum. Starts doing this thing.
It's already more to crunch. Oh my
God, I'm going to be actual lunch man.
The music, every time they stepped up
to the micro over time. Some parents,
it's kind of weird to wear your own GE.
Ha.
Like should I get t hats and wear them?
Would you wear a t hat?
You're t hat, I'm wearing
mine. You are yours. Well,
I've wheeler Walker Jr hats and I put it
on once, you know, if I forget a habit,
I just, I feel so stupid wearing, it's
so dumb because as you, well, it's like,
it's kind of like, can I, can I say
it from the jump? What are ready?
I'm annoyed with, with him
is this phony Baloney. I'm,
I'm just a humble boy from
Oklahoma and you know, and he like,
he's so accepting like,
oh,
run the tractor from across
the water to a humble boy.
Oh, you can't say Angland mode fucker.
Yeah, well that's cross the water.
The other thing too that I don't,
that annoys me is like the hottest
shit right now is that movie and Queen.
So he's like, no, it's
really about me. You know,
it's like people are missing
the point of the movie,
which the point of the movie is the Garth
loves queen. That's Louie. How he sees,
he has to make it about his queen
resurgent is about Garth loving, ah,
forgot the garlic.
Loved him before the movie.
Just to just like make a movie with
a reminder. There's a Ge logo here.
There's a Ge logo here. Yeah, there's
a Ge logo here. There's a Ge logo here.
All right, go ahead. Go.
They what was impossible and impossible
was every day thing for them.
Yeah.
It's all done in a zillion part.
Harmony.
Find me somebody
that tap
Jesus Christ.
Man,
I think he just came in his pants and
he's young and he's also just like,
you know, he's, he wants it to look
like he's, he's conducting queen.
He writes do this was
recorded 30 years ago.
Motherfucker like he has a part of it.
There's a check this shit out right here.
Like that. Just like, yeah. He's like,
he's like, as if he quieted them down,
say no dude, that song's been the
same since we've been listening to it.
So insufferable. Got, yeah, the
ego. He's such a weird fucking guy.
He should've played fraud mercury
and they'd be like, you know,
we had this one weird guy. I auditioned
for it. You're weird as fuck too.
Why don't you do it? Well, he did
want it to be Chris, the Chris Gaines,
his foray into that be crazy.
If he's like,
he got his demand is people putting it
on. He's like, he thinks he looks like,
I think I'll go to make it. Listen, I
don't look exactly like him, but you know,
get the guys who did fucking
jar jar just make me look like
a total where he just like, he had
aids. Man, you're like, you just,
you're way too much.
There's nobody that sounds like Wayne.
And that just tells me how far
ahead of their time they find me.
Somebody to love digging into those lyrics
that no matter how different mean you
are,
the basis thing is
again, with this love one another
bullshit. He invented that by the way.
You know what we were just talking
about the darkest motherfuckers,
Michael Jackson, who
else? Uh, the cause they,
cause they all have these
bullshit and messages of like,
he takes kind of love the world.
You get a huge world with love.
Meanwhile they're doing dark stuff
behind closed doors. Uh, Garth doc,
40 years from now. Oh, 100%
there. And it'll be like all,
they'll just show footage. Like this
guy, he was always like, hi y'all. Hi.
Got To waving and smiling and then you
know his billboards like let's just let
us love one another
and then it'll be like,
and this is where he cut people's hands
off and it'll be like on his ranch.
I could see him.
He looks like he like works out,
but it looks like there's a
little extra pounds from, well,
yeah.
Well I watched Tricia's baking channel
and he and Trish make a lot of bad treats.
Like it's, you know, corn
flake, peanut butter balls.
Can you see on one day watching that
you see like a fingernail or something?
She's like, what is this? He's like,
I'll tell you, I keep finding these air.
I don't know what this is, baby.
Just some bullshit spin on it.
Oh boy.
Chen had a body and find me all
the stuff that separates us,
that divides us, the draw
boundaries between us. He says,
find me somebody to love and all of that.
There's the message for me, for him,
for him forever. God, I never
look at lyrics that way.
You actually know that the lyrics were
about something besides you. Right.
He thinks is funny. Some might
love was written about the garden.
He thinks they took a time
machine and like it's so, yeah,
you're absolutely right. Really
like he took away too. Yeah.
But it ends with like, uh, like the like
the logo Bohemian rhapsody like it's a,
it's like a Promo for the movie that
the movie didn't even want. I was like,
I love that movie.
I'm going to make them a promo.
And I think they thought they were
gonna use it at the Oscars or something.
Every time he wants to really make
a point on any of his social media,
he always always goes to,
and then I,
he talks like that always has to
do is sexy voice and like it's,
it's so forced and it's,
it just sends shivers.
I really liked that.
Really like that
kind of like his weight.
It's like,
it's like you're still the same dumb
fucking yeah. Thought. It's just softer.
It is. It is a soft or dumb thought.
I'm, I'm a step above you. I,
you guys could use it in the morning.
He'll respect him. I don't know.
I just think he's fucking
sucks. Wow. I think he's,
he's eating the big three for me on town.
Annoying and fat.
Where do you fit on that scale?
Well, I think, um,
Bert Kreischer we certainly got the
fat and he's certainly got the, um, no,
I don't find them as well. I personally,
I don't hang out with them enough.
I'll bet he could hit two of those and
you know,
yeah. I haven't spent any,
maybe definitely near the end
of that when I'm on the podcast.
Like two more hours. He would, he would,
he could get into Garth's, right? Yeah.
I don't think he eats people though or no,
I don't know either.
I don't think so either.
But it's good to know that the
Burt's on his way to be quick card.
Well yet be cool if he could sell
out of Notre Dame. Fuck. Here we go.
Here's the Weirdo.
Everyone had Garth Brooks here
in iconic Notre Dame locker room.
This is where the players go out
to take the field every Saturday.
This is where all our players are
getting ready to take the field for this
concert. So tonight the fighting Irish,
they're going to become the singing Irish.
This is going to be good.
Can you just picture him on the way up?
Teams have players, bands have played on.
Just came up with that role started from,
and do you also,
you realize too that there'll be like,
there's like a CBS executive is like, Hey,
we were thinking for the Promo.
He was like,
I got the fucking promo
and then he wrote the copy.
You guys think hundred
percent yeah, no, I think,
oh my gosh.
Jesus
legendary coach had this sign put up.
That's now probably one of the most
famous sides and football history.
Play like a champion today.
I love that.
But look at his face right there.
Just even see that's why that smiles,
that skeletons exactly.
Fingers chopped off in a bowl somewhere.
He only smiles with his mouth,
never his eyes.
That's how you can tell a smile is fake.
He says there's just butts stuff going on.
Yeah.
Do you wear wheeler on stage?
Do you do the the Janet
Jackson headset or do you do
her phone? I do them. I would
never wear that headset.
It's the fucking corniest thing ever.
Stupid.
But that's the thing too is
like what does he need it for?
He's not going of course at dancing,
but don't forget the old early days,
like when he used to come into my
home town, he would, they'd pull them,
they'd be hanging from that fucking wire,
you know,
flight fly around like Bon Jovi. Now he's
too fat for that show. And the wired,
you know, he's, he's worth
too much to too many people.
The wire would fucking break and now
he's just kind of got that place.
Yeah, that's his name. It his
biography to five for the wire.
They used to fly him around there.
I did not know.
Now what is it?
I have friends in low places and
then he's up high. Is that the,
they probably tried to rig it
once, you know, and they're like,
this thing's not really flying
because the a special light at Notre Dame
and keep the party going by streaming
all of our music exclusively
on Amazon music. Hey Alexa,
do you have friends in low places?
Sometimes, but they aren't big on
social graces. She got to love that.
He's the
only person who likes it. Yeah. Yeah.
You know his music, it's not on iTunes.
I was going to ask you that.
Do you know what the deal is with that?
Why is he doing that? Yeah, no, he, he um,
well what happened was when
iTunes and all the other,
like Spotify came out and he decided
to make like I'm not making this up,
like not instead of MP,
he decided to make his own format.
Like instead of MP three, he had like
a GP P G's. Yeah. It was like, yeah,
it was like Julio g p three.
Yeah.
It was like eight or
whatever it was like his own,
he was like going to come up with a
better one than my own form. I said,
put it on my fucking, you know, just,
I'm bigger than apple. I'm doing,
I've got a g phone, I don't
have an iPhone. Exactly.
Exactly. Yeah. I'm sure someone,
some asshole wants to write
g cross out all the eyes.
But he tried to compete with them,
but come up with a format.
So they,
and the also,
he didn't want to give them the
30% cut that like everybody does.
And so then he got, he,
he was like, I'll just be,
he put out an offer to all
of them, whoever's going
to pay me the most gets it.
Cause I ain't playing all your
fucking games, you know. So he's like,
Amazon made the biggest offer and he's,
you can only get it on Amazon. Yeah.
So if you, if you're, if you've got
an iPhone, you don't have Amazon,
you don't hit guard,
you don't get the card.
Oh Wow. I'm really, it's gotta
be the one of the only, I mean,
I know about title and all that,
but it's like he's gotta be the only
major artists where you can't hear one
fucking thing
on iTunes. Nothing silly. Yeah. Yeah, no,
there was weird sometimes
on the country charts like,
like iTunes will sell like um,
you know,
like some no name or somebody
playing the hits of Garth.
That'll actually just to just to get some
Garth on there. Yeah. Or like, you know,
like not a fake Garth, but you know,
attribute to Garth Brooks will actually,
people will buy that cause they're
good when they searched Garth,
nothing comes up except for,
you know,
but I think it's a blessing because I
actually want to take my shit off Amazon
so I'm not being sold
anywhere where Garth is.
I like that too. Hello? I like that. He
always says that at the end of everything.
And I, and I really love that
and isn't that I like that. Oh,
you can't come up with another tagline.
It's called the word of life.
Student body calls a touchdown.
Jesus because it overlooks the north
end zone here and the house that Rockne
bill touchdown.
Jesus was assembled by stone,
gathered from all seven continents.
This is the place,
this is where everybody comes together.
All religions, all shapes and sizes.
And they're all here to sing.
That's what I love about it
today. I love, I would
love to see him like that.
Like the footage after when
they're like in now, just uh,
we're going to take you down this way.
He's like,
why the fuck am I up here right now?
Like I would love to see him snap
and drop the wholesome thing,
you know,
and eat like a camera man saying
just take a bite. Well I told him,
I was telling you guys
before you didn't know this.
So apparently that Notre Dame concert,
it was so big that you'll
usually for live concert movies,
they'll do two shows and
pick the best of both cases.
Miss miss a note here or there, but he's
like, I'm playing two fucking shows.
So if you, if all those hundred thousand
people, if they fucked up a song,
they had to do it again.
You had to sit there at live at a concert
you paid money for and if he fucked up,
you had to start from the beginning.
Beginning again. The live TV taping. Yeah,
Jesus, 700,000 and it's like
five hours long. Yeah, no,
it was, it was a little long.
We'll just do two shows because that's
how long it'll take you five hours
anymore. Well, he don't got
that kind of time, you know?
Yeah.
France in Notre Dame stadium
didn't rhyme or it doesn't fit. No,
it does.
Since then, have you had one more hit that
people know that you can read it? Yeah,
yeah, yeah. I got friends
in Notre Dame stadium.
Legend has it that knew Rodney said this
when we're on the road where somebody
else's gas, let's play in a way that never
lets him forget that we visited them.
That's what we're doing tonight.
And new.
You're not going to forget this concert
day. How many times? Not really bad.
I'd forgotten like since it aired. Yeah.
Yeah. Well you think of that buckle.
That's like intense buckle,
right? Well I don't,
they'd light and the light blue denim on.
And then is he wearing dark
denim or is it black pants? Uh,
I think he's wearing just Dickies.
You know,
he's going to go keep it real
grounded. Oh, sure. Yeah, yeah. No,
those are elastic pants.
I'll bet you that, that those pants
come like with the buckle, like sewed on
children's story. Everybody. Garth
Brooks here, this is going to be good.
I love that.
I got to love that.
Touchdown. Jesus. Touchdown.
Jesus. All shapes and sizes.
That's what I love. Not
any times. Don't miss it.
Shit man. I was tripping. I was
really good man. He's awesome at work.
Um, so listen, I hate guards. You had
Garth, but we love Wheeler Walker Jr.
So can we can we can hear
something off the new album. Yep.
Track from the new record because,
you know, like I said, I kind of,
I'm going to take a song
that's not exactly the most
of its love songs and songs
about my son,
but I s I haven't played this song live
yet and I want you guys to hear it. It's,
yeah, it's a song about, um,
my experiences and what it takes to be
the king of country music like I am.
Okay. It's called a sucked
another dick last night.
I'm gonna take my headphones off.
Sure.
It's a good song for Potter to listen
to too. Yeah. How appropriate. Well,
Josh Potter, you just had a
conversation about second decks. Yeah,
no,
the day last night.
No less wrong or right.
First few.
And I'm blue.
I could blame on the booze,
but now it's just something I do.
We didn't feel so don't get up tight.
No other Dick last night.
MMM.
Now I'm Darlin don't get me wrong
and be few had a down.
Please don't tell our son cause he
won't understand about his cock.
Goblin comes while running crazy old man.
Please.
Except only for the gala and him.
Not what I do when the,
hey,
another dick last night.
Not saying that's wrong or right,
first few and I blew.
I could blame on the
booze,
but now it was just something I do.
We didn't feel so,
don't get uptight,
but I sucked.
No other deck last night.
Darlin stabbing,
yelling down the baby's asleep.
Didn't kiss neither.
You until I brushed my teeth.
Now I need you to stop
all this judging of movie.
The good Lord made all of us differently.
He,
he
as another day.
Last night.
Not saying
that's wrong or right.
First few.
And I'm blue.
I could blame on
booze now.
I was just something I do.
We didn't fuck.
So don't get up tight
once a month that most,
not all the time.
You have to trust it. Allow me. All right.
But I served another dick last night,
but I served another dick last night.
Wow.
You see how mature and as an artist
that was really not taking serious shit
cause we're doing it without
crying. That's a beautiful
song. Thank you man. Yeah.
And that's on the album? Yeah. It's on the
new album, ww three available on iTunes.
It's an Amazon exclusive.
No, I didn't know. Fuck,
I didn't know that about,
about this album.
I feel so stupid for not like
investigating. You know what, you,
you're busy people.
You got into a whole new fucking studio
filled with books or whatever it is.
You got shit to do and you got
to read all these books, man.
How far are you into these boats getting
started? I haven't started yet. Yeah,
we gotta you gotta read them. It's
looks like good shit. Yeah, no,
that's awesome man. I love it. And yeah,
it's a definitely turning a corner.
It's a more mature wheeler for sure.
I mean, I've been hearing that a lot.
Just kind of like, people are like,
why'd you go so serious? I'm like,
it's serious shit. Is this 2019 the
serious shit going? Yeah. I'm growing up.
I'm married, I've got a kid, I'm,
I'm fucking mature. You know?
Here's my song about sucking
dicks. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wow. I'm a, I'm like affected by
that too. It is nice to see you.
Growing up I was, I was a little
worried about you. You only mold,
people get worried, but you know,
I'm always going to, you know,
I still feel like it's still me.
You know?
It is because I remember
last time we spoke, you know,
think your mom went to one of your shows
and she was like, God, I have, I mean,
you know, you sing so beautifully in
this one. She loved this one. She loves,
she understands where I'm coming from.
It's like serious stuff, you know? Yeah.
So now she gets it. Yeah, it took a while.
But this is a song like that that like,
you know what? Our Son
has a heart. He's serious.
He's an artist. That's what I
wanted to hear. How about your dad?
He still thinks I'm a fucking degenerate,
but he's also fucking asshole. Yeah,
I don't care about him. Yeah, he's a Dick.
Tell us about it. I Dunno, but I
told you, I tell you that some,
there's a guy on Twitter who claims to
be my dad wheeler walker senior anyway,
and he yells at me every fucking day.
Really? That he's, yeah, that he's like,
but what's weird is I haven't told him
to stop because he does sound like,
I don't know how he know.
He just like eat everyday tweets that
he's disappointed with me and he hates me
and I wanted to say, you know, get my
manager or something to take it down.
But it's, it's pretty close to what my
dad's actually like. I enjoy reading it.
Is Your Dad, is he like, you know, you
with this nonsense music? Is he like,
is he like that? Well, he's like
that until I buy them. You know,
a fucking fucking airpods,
you know, and then he's like,
well, you know, he's a fan.
He's like, it's like headphones
or no fucking cords, you know.
And then all of a sudden he's like,
oh this, this, these songs are dirty.
But they're pretty cool because he can't
fucking afford airpods fucking life
depended on it. You did. You guys have
an air pocket. Cool. I don't have him.
I got, but I don't want them.
No, you need fucking half too.
I feel like the strong army and all
this new shit. It's fucking cool.
I was just talking about that with a
friend of mine the other day about,
he was talking about, he has
like PC products, you know,
for Mac or whatever it's called.
Um, but like I want stuff made by,
I don't like the Fuck Bill Gates, you
know, given all that money to charity.
I want the asshole who hates who, just a
fucking Dick who's focusing on the shit.
Yeah. Bill Gates, all his
shit as courts. I want that.
The air pods with the no cords because
that dude hated everybody and wanted to
get back at people.
So we figured out how to make the fucking
headphones with no court dates is just
spending money like saving Africa. Fuck
off. Fuck all that shit. Just focus dude.
By the way, I will give you a break on
any air chartering you're looking for,
uh, in future towards
with this plane on, right?
I'm sure you're at that level.
I looked into it,
but I don't think I'm going to get it.
Well,
I am and I just wanted to extend
that to you. I'll give you, yeah,
I'm, I'm I to admit I'm lost
by private jet. I'm buying,
I'm pretty close to it as a no,
we lost a major sponsor,
Mcdonald's this show,
and we got two point $3 million and then
they saw our content and they pull the
money. So we don't have the money
anymore. Tom. I don't know their money.
And that's not what I'm saying is Morton,
we're the only,
only gave us two grand over
Morton's completely. And by the way,
I like Larson's a lot more than Morton's,
just so that the Morton's people
can hear that. Well, I can,
I just tell you right now,
can I just say a lie to your face?
I'm going to stop eating Mcdonald's
in protest. Thank you very much.
I appreciate that.
It's not really that good or convenience.
Right. That's a friend right
there. Thank you for if my,
if Mcdonald's link there to buy my
friends at jet. Fuck them. No, I know.
I'll give you six to 8% off
any, any charters you're
looking for until you cool,
man. What's his company? It's
just could be Tom's planes. Oh,
I thought you were about to do a promo.
No, no, no. I'm just letting you know.
It looks like you guys are
in our fucking nail it.
If you've got private jets sponsoring
this show, that's next. Yeah.
If someone said, someone said there's
like an Uber for jets now. Yeah. Yeah,
that'd be cool. Yup. Yeah.
Well it sounds like a Tom.
I have just signed you up for it. Oh my
God. Who's more responsible with money?
You or your wife? I mean my, I mean, not
even close. It's her. I mean, I buy stuff.
I mean, you don't need eight pairs airpods
but you know you've eight pairs. Well,
I just kept, I just, I go to the
store and then I was like, I want to,
you know that feeling you get
when you buy something cool.
And I love them so much.
I want to go to the store.
I want to have the feeling
it's on buying it again.
You keep buying them just to have that,
get the excitement. I want a new one.
People are like those nerves or
into the open box openings. Yeah.
I've opened that box and smell
nice sweet fucking airport plastic.
When you're on the road,
it's like when you're on the road busting
your ass and you haven't showered for
days, you know you're fucking
hung over. It's like, oh,
this is what I do it for fucking two
little thing in my ears. I can roll over.
I can put my hands here. I don't have to,
he can roll over. You can do anything.
Yeah. I mean like I've, I can do, you can
do it. I've tried to lay, I shake my head.
Those things don't fit for you. Then
the other not good. Great for that.
They look like they're going to fall out
of it scares me and I like that they're
so fucking good.
Really.
I mean to me like my favorite artist of
all time are probably Waylon Jennings,
Willie Nelson and airpods.
Wow.
Which I think airpods or not
as good as Willy Nelson. Right.
This so you're a big
air pod guy. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm hoping that they listen to this
and send me some more shit. Sam.
Eric at. Yeah. Me. They'll just send
you some money for this free promo.
This is a great promo. Yeah. I
mean with between jets and airpods,
someone should step up. Yeah. Okay. Um,
are we gonna hit another song? I
could play you want, if you love to,
I love your songs. Do you want to hear
the hit from this record? The one that,
according to my people, this is my
biggest hit in a while. It's cool.
I like smoking pot a lot.
Let's do it.
Let me keep the on and see
what that experience is. Okay.
Some people smoking meth
so people smoke crack.
Some people snort coke
offer Rick his mouth.
Sec Have Trad.
Amal,
don't get me wrong.
There is
comes from
smoking pot a lot and
getting stoned all alone.
I like vaping. We didn't, they,
I think it it bows are incredible.
Asher loved them. Gummy
Blair's Ham, shampoo.
Shampooed former curly hair's
rubbing. Kana Biz, low shin,
no Mac. Ah, black smoking.
So people lack pills.
Some like huffing glue.
But that ain't breaking news.
Some people add booze,
some black silk in downs,
brother [inaudible]
but that's another song
I just played it for you
a lot.
Smoking pot a lot.
Getting stoned or vaping.
We need
it.
It bools are incredible.
Ash Love Lamb.
Gummy bears.
Damn.
Shamp food for my curly hair's
rubbing cannabis lotion.
Oh no Mac.
Ah,
a lax smoking pot a lot.
Smoking pot
lacks smoking.
Pat. Uh, Ooh.
Thank you very much. That was beautiful.
Amazing Wheeler. That was, wow.
Thank you so much that they
can't get any better. It's like,
it just keeps getting better and
better. That's how I feel too. Yeah.
It's like was you know those, those,
you've had that pride in comedy.
We just kind of,
you just get that lightening bolt.
You're just like sitting
around trying to write a song.
You're like pot smokers with the lot.
No one's ever thought about that. Yeah.
It's all me, man. I'm going to hurt, you
know? Yeah. Yeah. You killed it, man.
Great work. You guys are the best man.
Love you. Love. It's good to be here.
It's so great. It's so great to have
you here. I want people to make sure.
Can I see that album? You hand it to me or
toss it or whatever. Yeah, there you go.
Boom. And maybe we go in on
this one here. Check it out.
Is that a good place
to hold it? Yeah. Boom.
Ww three available and all we'd w three
is that your wife right there? Yes sir.
Oh Man. That's awesome.
Let me see. There you go.
She's a little upset that I showed the
kid on the back of the CD, but it's like,
you know, I ain't hide anything
from my audience on Instagram. Yeah,
I know this person.
Yeah. Gorgeous. Really,
really beautiful angel guys out to fight.
That's Mrs. Walker right there.
How exciting.
You're cool.
You guys are cool to leave
comments about how you want to,
she don't mind if you want to tell her
that you find her sexy and want to whack
off to her, whatever she likes,
that kind of thing. Yeah,
because it doesn't piss
her off as my point is,
and it doesn't offend me because I
know that I've got to catch, so, yeah.
That's awesome man. I like that about
you. Um, are you going to be now?
You're probably won't be there.
You're not going to be,
you're going to be in la for a little bit.
I'm going to be in Nashville next month.
Next month.
I might be there and we'll see, but
all right. Um, yeah, I'm out here.
We're trying to make a wheeler movie
and I fucking hate la too much.
God Damn word. You got fucked out of
a deal before I want to tell my story.
You know Bohemian Rhapsody's hot,
we got this Elton movie coming out.
You've got fucking stars born. It's
time for wheeler, you know, 100% yeah.
Long over. Damn man. I remember
watching, I was watching the Oscars.
I see that Shitty lady got gas,
Cooper Barton it in, you know, it's
like, I can do this in my fucking sleep.
That was my first thought when
I saw that shit. I was like, oh,
wheeler can nail this. So yeah. I mean,
how am I crazy? But did Brad Cooper,
Brad Coop,
let Bradley Cooper whatever his name is,
sound like fucking shit garbage.
I can't, I can't listen to slow,
boring, heartfelt. You know what
I mean? It's like, it's bullshit.
It's not actually with lame ass lyrics.
Yeah. I mean the lyrics were just like,
we thought the movie was
stupid. I could, I could you,
you couldn't pay me to want to
take lady Gaga. I think lady Gaga,
I should fall down the stairs.
Crane. Yeah, you're the best band.
You're the best. Whaler I really
am, but I really appreciate it.
You guys are the best here.
You guys are the best in the
podcast business. And like,
I'm like, everything you say I want,
like I want to buy Postmates. Right.
Go get on Postmates right
now. Good. I didn't even know
you could do it in hotels.
Oh, I do it all the time.
Yeah, I've done it. I did it a,
when we had to evacuate our house for
fires, we went to a hotel at night.
First thing I did, I called, I did
Postmates and brought us groceries.
You could send it to other people.
I spent like 40 hotdogs of Burt's house.
Oh really? A hope I can do I know
where those hot dogs or they're gone.
They're gone. Yeah. Yeah. It's pretty
great man. I'm going to send [inaudible],
send some hot dogs to my wife
and I live here. Yeah, this
sounds great. Um, any, uh,
live dates coming up. I know you taking
a little break right now. I'm just,
I'm Kinda, I'm kind of, um,
want to get out to see I it to,
I need people to take a break from wheeler
for a little bit. I just need, uh, to,
um, I've just been on
the road just like three.
I did three albums and three years. It's
like, it's another for awhile. It's, yeah,
it's like a, you know, I want to,
I want people to miss me. Sure.
And I'm announcing that
on your Mama's house. Wow.
Please miss me.
Well,
in the meantime,
download ww three by check
it out by on vinyl CD sounds.
What sounds way better on vinyl.
I'll tell you that. Yeah. I liked,
I liked listening on vinyl. Now that
we've got that record player, I really do,
man.
I could get a record player on a jet.
Elvis had a record player.
Oh see, you know Elvis had a record
player in his Cadillac. Oh, even? Yeah.
That's great. Can you do that with all
the records? It's scratch people. Avi,
he's like someone, someone told him
that too and he's like, fuck you put it.
He probably hired someone that just put
that needle back like over and over,
you know, put it back at the right place.
Work. But it just like you tell
Elvis. No. Right. Good luck.
Yeah, a man. Well, thanks for
coming by again. We will have me.
I love having you and um,
yeah, we'll see you guys too.
We'll be back to getting
physical after this quick break.
All right. We're back. And it is
beyond a pleasure and an honor.
You don't know how,
how hard I'm geeking out right now.
I can finally say short dogs in
the house. Uh, two shorts here,
which is surreal to say Kevin [inaudible]
in the house. Yeah, you could say,
yeah. Short dogs in the house.
Kevin blast in the house. Uh,
you guys have the blow the
whistle show that uh, people can,
you're now going to put it in more
places, you're telling me, right?
Yeah. It's very soon it's going to
be uploaded to iTunes and Spotify.
We had some issues with copy
written music, beef. Yeah.
So I, for now though,
it can be where accessed
dash radio and mixed cloud.
You could find some of our older shows,
but dash radio, every Tuesday night
we have a show from six to eight,
a mix tape and then eight
to 10 on hip hop acts.
So there's an encore performance of how
did you guys hook up? Man, this is wild.
It was, I just know kb from
where we're homies, right.
We started off doing parties together.
His uh, him and his brother promote,
promote parties, uh,
generally around porn events.
So from the start,
the very first party I did with them,
it's porn influenced him. Just,
you know, it, it turned out to be,
you have a lot of fun,
even make a couple of business
opportunities and stuff
and just things happening.
So,
you know,
after awhile we started being friends and
if you notice just now you know Katie,
right? No, you don't know him. No.
He was the one comic at the
store that I don't know. Oh, he,
he doesn't talk like that. No, I'm a
white guy. That's really a black guy.
Give him a microphone. He starts going
and I used to go to broadcasting school.
Automatic shitty does,
but he gets on the,
every time we do an intro, say, hey guys,
you're listening to all the west
will radio. Yeah. Shut the fuck.
Turn into Mr. Broadcaster Guy. I'm a strip
club Dj. All slash gym club Dj. Okay.
Okay. So that's why I got that from me.
I got to say I'm, I'm s I look there,
you know how there's a certain album
moms are music where it's like a time
capsule where it takes you to like a
certain era in your life.
Yeah. So I remember I moved,
I was living in the suburbs of Milwaukee
and we moved freshman year of high
school.
So it's like a fall of
93 I moved to Florida,
Vero Beach,
Florida.
And I remember it was like one of
the first days I met at the school,
but the middle of school year,
Steve Renick comes up to me and he's like,
we're playing football has just ended,
some were in the locker room and he's
like, do you burn bro? I was like, what?
He's like, you smoke trees and shit. And I
was like, oh yeah, I mean, you know? Yeah,
I get, yeah. And then he's like, what of
music you listened to? And I was like,
I dunno. I like hip hop. He's like, you
down with too short. I was like, what?
I didn't know. And he was
like, check this shit out.
So he gave me getting where you fit in.
That shit stayed in my CD player,
not just through freshman year through
getting my learner's permit through
getting my driver's license.
You're telling me that too short
helped you learn how to drive? I mean,
I was like, I want to be a pimp. This
is what I'm going to do with my life.
It was under the tape to the tape gets
stuck in your machine. It was man,
it was my,
it was that as a sign of the CD.
So CD he waited till the skip to Oh yes,
two matches up. Got a note, a new one.
Lean in, you know, with the hat, the
black hat to the side. And I was like,
this is what I want to do with my life,
man. I was like, well, you know it,
a lot of people get it,
but the majority of people don't get it.
That part of the, the two short
legacy, the, the things that uh,
make certain songs timeless. Yeah. Is
that it's uh, it's very informative.
Very Educational, very motivational.
Absolutely. It's, it's, it's almost like,
um, like a motivational
speaking technique thing. Sure.
Because when I write songs,
I don't write songs and,
and say things like everybody.
Yeah, I'm really wrap from me.
They're like one person.
Yeah. And many listeners,
like if you were in your car by yourself,
you'd like,
this motherfucker's talking to me. Like,
especially like songs, like getting it,
it's just like talking to somebody
like you got to get, I write like that.
So I just,
I make references like I'm just talking
to you and it makes everybody like act
like they, they think they know me
when they see me and I'll kind of shit.
So it works but, but when you add
up, add them all together. Yeah,
all the albums, all the songs and just
the ones that you gravitate towards.
After awhile you look back and go to
sharp taught me some shit. Yeah, man.
Absolutely. You did teach me some shit.
He's looking at me like I'm crazy now.
I know.
It's funny we
had it, but I'm just listening
the way rappers think lake,
we had big daddy Kane in here and
he talked about studying the greats,
his whole thing. He listened to Marvin
Gaye and he kind of was like, oh,
that's how you're, you're,
you know a, and I'm
listening to you talk
and your whole thing is,
I'm not talking to millions of people.
I'm going to talk to one person.
So my wheels are just turning it.
How different rappers approach a persona.
You gotta figure out how to
maximize presenting that and stuff.
He knows same thing on the
stage with comedy, whatever.
Same thing with acting methods and
stuff. But you know, big Daddy Kane,
he as some point,
so many ladies wanted to like fuck him.
I guess. He's like, he realized
he was a sex symbol and he's,
he started his early days.
He was just like, uh,
a tech to Mc that would just
attack you and just, yeah,
just murder you on the microphone. And
then he turned into a sex symbol. So,
you know, it's interesting though,
because like what you just said,
that sounds silly,
but Oprah Winfrey talks about that too.
And she talks to the audience.
She's not talking to millions of people.
She's like,
I'm talking to one woman who was
sitting in her living room right now,
or she probably liked me early on. Learned
that that thing works. That personally,
how did you figure that out?
Uh, doing shows, just, um,
I perfected my technique riding on the
public transit bus with a big ass radio
and wrapping at like really hardcore
ghetto house parties where two things on
the bus,
if you plan some music to the public as
like loud and obnoxious and somebody is
gonna say, turn that shit off,
you're gonna get like, like,
like some kind of back back lash. But,
but people used to like love my shit.
And then at house parties
it's like, it's, you know,
you're at a party where there's no
rules, regulations, there's no security.
There's, there's just
people who, uh, you know,
have quick tempers and they
don't tolerate bullshit.
So I used to go to those house parties
and and rock the really rough crowds and
shit and I knew I could do it
and that was the all confidence.
So later in life she just was like,
it was almost easy for me to like to
present the two short persona and nobody
was doing,
what was that doing that back in the day
either rappers weren't really cursing
alive, they really weren't
talking about pimp shit. They was,
it was a very new area and
like when he got that CD
he's like pimping,
you know,
remind me.
It was like I used to have to go to the
basement to watch def jam or like Eddie
Murphy.
I could not like sometimes I would put,
I give a CD to like my parents have
put in the car and that shit would be
permissible. Like fat boys are
like run DMC to show. I was like,
give me that shit man. I know
he's got secret. Yeah. Yeah.
He was saying like dirty,
like I still love,
I
can't tell you how many times,
just like endless hundreds,
thousands of people who have come to
me and said I got caught listening
too short when I was little and I got
my ass whooped. Yeah, yeah, for sure.
Like lots of gas weapons.
Yeah. I mean you said some foul
shit,
but you also had,
remember I told that story on our show
about how he brought it back to New York
and the Dominicans all her too short
and then he became a hero and he stopped
being picked on. He was the coolest
guy in New York. Yeah. But um,
my favorite is the one where you get
to borrow mom's car or something. Yeah.
Accidentally. And then
she gets in. It's like
we have to talk, but you know,
know something. I'm still alive.
I was in high school, I started writing
really dirty rhymes in high school. Yeah.
I learned, I learned early on the
first time I've said a curse word.
It was like I said something like
I had 10 holes, second 10 toes,
and this was like,
I was in 10th grade that play.
And people just laugh and I'm like,
I'm about to write a song about all 10
of these hoes and tell you how I met them
all and just tell you a story about my
10 holes. And it just, it just escalated.
And um, I just don't know. I just,
I just swear I learned early on man that,
that,
that talking shit just yeah,
but also like, you know,
Talk Shit. Uh, but you also had like,
you were drawn to like funky ass base.
Well the music is the sneaky, right.
I mean that's the, that's what
I am an old lady telling me, um,
I love your music. It's like don't
really care for the words. Right.
But I loved the music. Yeah. Yeah. We're
still a compliment to you though, man.
She's like, she's, she's developed a
technique where she could just ignore me.
Yeah. And they caught the man.
Who Do you think it came?
Cause it sounds like the bus and all that,
that's it's equivalent to like what the
open mic is for the comedian. You know,
you're doing sometimes harsh bars and
biker bars and places where they don't
want to fucking hear you taught.
So you better come in some shit that's
going to get attention and you talk about
some too short stuff,
you're going to get attention.
You're talking about
bitches fucking your stuff.
And I had a rat partner in high school
and our f w when we decided to try to
sell our music in the streets,
our first customers were drug
dealers who were actively working.
Really so because the logic was, well,
if you want to sell it, who's got money?
Right? So instantly we, uh, we got,
we got a drug dealer to
buy one tape and then, um,
the other guys around where like,
I want one too.
So the next day we came back and sold
him some more tapes and it was each like,
uh, uh, tape you had to make, you know
what I mean? The set tapes. Yeah, I would.
I would.
Um,
we would record a tape and then we copy
it a few times and then I'm literally
the drug dealers who were like three,
four blocks over,
they heard about it and they,
they sent word that bring on some of
those tapes to know and then we started
doing like a drug dealer
paper wrap kind of thing.
Like everywhere they would
congregate to sell drugs,
we'd pull up and they
started to be a thing.
Like I never had to try to sell music
at the supermarket or at school or
anything owner only drug
dealers in and everybody.
Did you foresee when you're selling the
drug dealers these that like this is
actually like, is it wild to you
that it turned into like legit? No,
we were in high school we were really
just trying not to work at mcdonalds and
shit like that. We went, we
were not trying to be stars.
We just wanting to get the money.
Do you ever have this? This is like,
do you ever have where you
listen to a song, any song,
and you realize you've been saying the
lyrics the wrong way. You ever had that?
Always do. Do you know that I
paid you right? You know I paid,
you know I licensed,
so in my last special I
licensed blowjob Betty.
Okay, okay. I paid you so
that I could say this line.
I fucking said it wrong. I've been
saying it wrong for 30 years or whatever.
What would you say? Check it
out. A bustle left nup right.
Not in a jaw. Sperm on her cheeks.
It's all dissolved. There you go.
It's all she saw that I said it wrong for
fucking since it came out. It was cool.
I was still made money back. It makes
sense though. I get my money back.
It makes sense. It is right. It
does kind of make sense, but anyway,
they're really dissolve though.
It kind of just,
did you feel bad when you killed her
with your nut? Can we talk about that?
That was actually like a proud moment
because if you analyze this story,
let's go through the store.
Let's go through the story.
The story starts off as a,
she was a girl who did business with
me and she was terrible at her job.
Her job was to actually go out and date
men and get their money and bring you
the money.
But she was such a party girl,
she'd fucking forget and like partying
just right. She'd forget the part to say,
pay me motherfucker. Yeah. So
we call those thrills secrets.
She wasn't really like about
that. That get that money. Yeah.
So I cut her loose and it just randomly
saw her one night doing her little party
girl thing and I'm like,
you know what?
I'm just going to step up to this
like angrily faced fucker. Yeah. Yeah.
So I did it. Yeah. And it just, it
was so much anger in it, so much,
you know, ah, yeah, fucking
despise you. And it just,
just hit that wrong pipe or
something like that. I Dunno. Yeah.
Then the next day you saw it on the news.
Yeah.
And the reason why it's not manslaughter,
it's because the shit was, um, considered
accidental. You know what I mean? Right,
right, right. Yeah. And it was a bunch
of guys. You couldn't say who did it.
There was no fucking, like, there
was a DNA test or shit like that.
So it was clear it was an act of God.
Wow.
That is like hearing the
story from the Bible to you,
like in a hostel. Yeah, that was great.
That was like the blowjob Betty story.
We just got to fucking hear
that. Yeah, and that's awesome.
But you're on your mom's house exclusive,
but it's a,
it's on the song in the song, you get to
hear you say it, to actually explain it.
Like I always thought about Betty,
all the music is so infectious.
And then in the end he goes,
I bust a nut and killed the bitch.
And you get a laugh and you're like, you
forget the whole how the story started.
Right.
But she was pretty shitty at her job.
Yeah,
true
man. I didn't even think about that whole
part. You don't even think about this.
She's had bad, she's bad
editor, John Mann storytelling.
How damn putting her in a position
where she fucking up from the start.
So you're not supposed to sympathize
with her dad and she's supposed to earn.
Yeah, she deserved that
Shit. Cause you had a lot,
I think I heard you say in an
interview you weren't a pimp,
but yet a lot of pimp affiliates so
well from Oakland. Yeah. You know,
anywhere you find a group of
pimps. One, I'm from Oakland.
I leave. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But um, I, um, I've never been a pimp,
but I have received money from
prostitutes. Does that make sense? I mean,
because just out of like love and
admiration, like is that why somewhat in,
in a couple of instances it was just
like grateful, like just being grateful.
I learned things from you. Uh, one
girl gave me a complete stranger,
walked up and gave me $1,800
bills and say it one line,
she said, you're the reason why
I'm hauling. Wow. I walked away.
I was in Las Vegas. Oh
Wow. And I looked at it,
I counted it. I turned
to my buddy. I'm like,
it's a chick just gave me $1,800
let's put it all in black.
I look around and there's nobody there.
It was like a fucking ghost. I don't know.
Damn. So yeah, you got a
story like that, Kevin.
I've got a lot of stories,
but none, no women have ever
given me $1,800. Yeah. Yeah.
So do you feel like though, cause I feel
like the, I already know the answer,
but if you were,
let's say tomorrow you wake up,
you got nothing to your name, you could
go out and pimp, like you know what to do.
Right? Well you know, during the
recession did a little pampering. You did.
And really, you know, the
economy was fucking up
the show money slow. Now promoters
weren't doing as many shows. Oh wait,
oh wait, oh, oh a 19 guys fucked up time.
So how do you find the house?
How do you find a girl who's like,
who's a good candidate throughout my
entire career and it's not sincere.
Like prostitutes really have
been flirting with me. Like,
like I went on a date with a chicken one
night and we went to breakfast at like
five in the morning and I
didn't know she was a hoe.
She's a very nice looking young lady
and she was questioning me a lot and I'm
like, why the fuck are you asking all
these questions? And she got to finish.
It's like, she's like, I thought you,
I thought this was like an interview.
I thought, you know. Oh
Wow. Really? I'm like,
oh you're a oh you know.
So things like that had
happened periodically
throughout my life. And I think,
um, I hang around so many
pimps. I grew up around it.
I really felt like it was an alternative
choice as far as a career options.
But my parents really
wanted me to go to college.
They weren't super happy
about the rap thing,
but then they would have been really upset
about the pimp thing if that. Yeah. So,
um,
along the way I learned
a lot cause I would,
I would actually study different things,
literature and stuff about pimping,
you know,
shit like a iceberg slim just let us,
it's a lot of shit out there
that you can read. Yeah.
On top of two short albums and,
and you know, too short songs,
you can go out there and really study what
this pimp thing is and it's not, it's,
you know, the, the ugly side
of it is the abuse and uh,
you know,
forcing of a woman to do things.
She doesn't want to do the physical
abuse deaths. That's the ugly side.
There's a completely different side that
is the more about what I like to rap
about it and putting the songs
and that's just like the finesse.
It's just finessing the situation, which
is a, you want to know who's a candidate.
Yeah. Um, prime candidates
would be like, okay,
we are in Las Vegas and he
had a few holes and slowly,
Michelle, you lost all your hoes. You
wake up one day, you got no Ellis.
It's known.
It's a known fact.
You can jump on the highway like maybe
the 15 drive up to Salt Lake City and you
know it's got, it's just a great place
to find holes. You know what I mean?
Why Salt Lake City?
Well let, let's be, let's be specific.
Why it like a little little lady like me.
I know I went to old to be a Ho. Let's
say it's me only 20 years ago. Am I,
am I somebody that could,
that you would choose as it came from?
I grew up in the San Fernando
Valley here. Los Angeles, La,
a lot of holes for late one
eight. Okay. But you know,
I'll give you another scenario cause she's
walking a resume is just like a bunch
of little, you know, little naive,
kind of not knowing kind of what you want.
Right.
Naive is what you need in that situation.
You wouldn't mind getting away
from the strict parents and shit.
They had a bad girl on the other side.
You go somewhere like Portland, Oregon.
Okay.
They've got like hundreds of strip clubs
and the stripper competition is like
way up there.
So in a lot of cases,
strippers or like working every
night making two, $300 bullshit.
You pull up in there and like
some fly ass car was so flyers,
jury asking questions like how
long have you been dancing?
About a year. Yeah. You know? Yeah.
Yeah. I've been about a year. It's,
I make like a couple hundred bucks a night
and I get to ask some questions like,
where do you live? How do you live?
What do you drive with my boyfriend, we,
we just ran a place around the corner,
probably like of struggling as boyfriend
type situation. He's, he's, you know,
he's a musician. Hey, I was
thinking pretty good. No
you're not. He's struggling.
He doesn't have a deal or anything.
Stupid ass questions like, have you,
have you ever been to Vegas? I've
been, yeah. I Love Vegas. I mean, no,
that's what they said. They say
so, so far, so far we're vibing,
right. And then you go get in the car,
bitch. So far as I should, right in
I, yeah, go ahead. The easiest
and quickest way is just
a bigger and better deal.
Oh Oh, so you I, yeah, so I'm like, I'm
paying up Jager. I'm painting a bigger,
better picture of everything
that's going on in your life.
And then I'm also informing you how,
no, not right off the back though.
But the numbers are really
great. It really great. How
much can I make with you?
Like if I go with you,
like I make $300 a night here and
you don't tell her right away.
You're going to be giving me
all the money. Well what? Well,
how does he get me to get in the car
and go and leave my stupid boyfriend and
stuff.
And then do you offer it to be mine?
I'm also establishing one thing that
you don't fucking have great money
management skills. You don't because
you're in a fucked up position right now.
You really drive a fucked up car.
Live in a fucked up place and
I don't, stupid ass. Yeah,
your shit together. Trust me. So in
Vegas though, literally though, um,
there have been times,
I don't know the economic state right now,
but I'm pretty sure it's pretty sure.
It's pretty good now because it
seems like a good time in the,
in the country as far as the economics,
people having money.
When people have money, they like
to buy Pussy, so, oh, perfect.
So that you're telling me
there's a lot of opportunity.
Now what about my boyfriend? Do I get
to bring him or do I leave him behind?
Who gives a fuck? Fuck the boyfriend.
I mean, who? I mean, who cares?
I don't know if you had a business
deal, you can look, I you,
it can be like Sharon Stone and casino,
you know what I mean?
Truck Double Life, whatever.
Um, but you should just,
the math is easy. You make about
five grand a week, you know? Wow.
That's really good. But then
when do you drink it? On average?
You should really do better than that.
What do you drop it on it?
But you're going to give that
all to me. Yeah. What's my take?
Any everything you want. What do
you want? I'm on five grand. No,
I'm saying what do you want? What do you
want? Oh, stuff. Yeah. What do you want?
I want, I want a nice house, I want a
nice car. I want like health insurance.
You can get my teeth fixed. You've got to
hold the fuck up. The more you hold up,
you don't get all that shit. Oh,
I'm gonna get a quick too quick.
And that's what I like. I like
quick handbags. Okay, so let me,
let me tell you another
story. Listen to a bitch. So,
so you're like really skeptical about
this. You're like, well I don't want to,
I don't know about selling my pussy
dance.
Yeah. So take your Shit a strip
club. Sure. Clubs are rough for like,
for like rookies and he'd come back,
bitches of remain to you can't
get none of the special favors.
That fucking haters too.
They all hate me.
They're putting you on the
stage when no money's out there,
like just all kinds of shit. And he's
just like, you're like, this is bullshit.
So what I would do is I would tell you
to go out on a date with a friend of
mine's girlfriend. Just go, just go
hang with her and watch what she does.
So she's going to take you to a hotel
room and a guy who's already been
prearranged is going to come in and pay
you guys two grand just to like dance or
Party and hang out with him and you
might be expecting to have sex with him.
He's gonna be like, Oh, I just wanted
to party and it gives you two ran here.
You come back to me and go, I made a
fucking thousand dollars doing nothing.
I love this shit. He's like, brilliant.
There's a thousand scenarios that,
and then,
and then there's the other side to where
you're coming from a really fucked up
situation. Yeah, the fucked
up life, like piece of shit.
People are doing bad things.
Even in the house you live in,
you fucking hate your life and you
like just quickly go black pimp,
take me away.
Take me away.
I love this dope white pimps too
are they're really dope white pimps. Yeah.
I mean it's, it's logic bros, like logic.
I'm, I do the shit and musically
entertainment. I find the humor in it.
I make it educational. But
also if it's fun, yeah.
I'm not giving you the dark side
of this shit gift of the Gab,
like the spitting game of it, all.
Everything, all that. Yeah. May of you.
If you're a really talented pimp, you, you
don't even ever have to touch her. Yeah.
Literally I'm told it's all in here.
Okay. Let's say there's a gentlemen,
a lot of money. He wants to do
something like he made me, he wants to,
he and his friend wanted a double anal
with me. I'm not sure I'm ready for that.
How do you talk me into
doing the double anal? Uh,
you would have a barter
system going on there. Okay.
And you'd call up another hole that
might not even be your pimps. Other hoe.
You might be like, bitch,
I got a job for you.
And then she's going to throw you a job
trade trader out. Like I'll be like, dude,
you take this double anal and I'll take
your pill or just throw me a favor later
because they should definitely going to
give her a whole bunch of money for that.
So there's a lot of money. He's going
to get a lot of money for a double anal.
What's that worth?
She better get about 2,500 per guy,
whatever this whole thing, 25 that
was very humiliating. So that's very,
that's probably a lot of,
it's not going to be good.
It's going to hurt
black pimp take me away.
I swear. I believe you. Wait,
so what's your percentage?
Oh of it or all of it? 100 and then
you get, the more you work you do,
you get spoiled. Yeah. So you just,
so you just had you decide like how
much of that I deserve per customer.
Like there's no fixed rate. You
get no money. Oh stupid bitch.
Oh you just keep me alive and like,
Oh shit. And then the fucking fly ass car,
he pays for the hemorrhoid cream. When
I get my nails done, my hair, it
gets done. That's all you do is work.
And you'd call it up and you
sit around and ball out and you,
and how much do I have to work like every
night or do I get a night off days too.
What's my schedule?
And that's funny too because it's,
and then this, this, this is
just from knowing their life.
Like literally you might have a guy
who's like, you know, go hit it like,
like four or five nights a week.
And the girl would be like,
I feel like I can get more.
And she'll be hitting that bank seven
nights a week on an on about choice.
And that's like there's
over overachievers,
they're in every walk of life.
This,
that is the best way to become a pimp
is to actually find yourself with a real
hole. Like before it, before you,
even when you're a rookie pimp,
you get a a veteran,
huh? Oh, right now. Okay,
so she kind of teaches you, it teaches
you how to be a pimp and then, um,
and then um,
just get your feet wet and then shit,
probably like bring you a couple
of a real hole can make a pimp.
She could like pick you.
Like you look like you could be a pimp.
You kinda got squashed. Do this,
dress like that, drive like that.
When you walk in the room,
act like that.
Then she'd go get him to other holes and
say I've got the greatest people in the
world.
Be with him.
Next thing you know you went from nobody
to walking around with three holes and
they bring in you how much?
20 nothing.
15,000 a week knowing I'm
sorry, that was my take. Sorry
I forget you get nothing. Any
spare cash. Don't know yet.
Like some spare cash like cause
how do I get out of Hawaii?
Like here's the deal man. Once I'm in the
hallway, okay, let's say I go with you.
I want to eventually I'm going to age
out of that shit. I'm sneaky. Whole Zoo.
Yeah.
Tell me what a sneaky Hode as Nicky House
make 1500 a night and come home with a
thousand. Oh she dare to not
give you all the cash. Yeah,
but she's sneaky as hell is good.
Their wigs pool, dines aside,
I wouldn't want to be dishonest.
Caught him escape plan.
That's how you do it though.
You Skim a little off the top
cause you look at your guy,
he might be like flamboyant and he's
buying you a BMW and buying him a Rolls
Royce. You're like, my beamer
was nice but look what he did.
And he's the Big Boston, you know
they get, they get mad a lot too.
He was getting mad of course, cause they
figure it out eventually. Like Whoa,
what the fuck man?
Like in my case I party a lot so I get
a random phone call and we were like
noise in the background and
then I'm like, hello. It's like,
oh you fucking party and I'm out here.
I just ran from the fucking
police and you're partying right.
So you just get like the whole blues.
That's why I'm in not that whole blood.
That's why I'm not a pimp.
I said that's the main reason why I'm
not a of those phone calls because of the
fucking psycho therapy.
The just the therapist part.
I don't like that part. Therapizing
the house that you got, you have to be,
you have to be all that shit.
You got to be a fucking father.
Oh fucking boss or fucking accountant.
Her motherfucking psychiatrist.
Oh yeah. And much bullshit. You know the,
just the whole venting and all this shit.
Talk Bob like talks,
talks. You don't want to hear that,
Kevin, you were throw that thing around.
Hoes don't appreciate they depreciate so,
oh sure. There's really no escape plan.
There's no four
o one k.
What about his porn star relationships?
You have points or relationships? I've
had many dated porn stars. Oh yeah.
This is something that shortcuts on
the about all the time. He's like,
you're not supposed to like
wife these girls up. Wham Bam.
Thank you ma'am. Relationships as Sam
triply would say, shout out to Sam.
I'm just, the guy looks
broken toys. I like the place.
He doesn't monetize the relationship.
He does. Yeah. Come on. Yeah,
I'm Jewish. I mean wait, so tell me
how though it's get up and go to work.
Go to work. You do. All
right. Well, you know,
you're one of these guys
who had zero though.
Insecurity about her doing her blow.
Bang. Never. Well, I never did blow bags,
so my last girl was a web cam
model. Okay. That doesn't sound,
they always have the web camera
and with their house. So, you know,
people would come over my
house and there'd be girls
sitting on balloons in the
other room doing all kinds of niches
and kind of looks like this room. Right.
And everybody's like,
I'm trying to watch a basketball game
and literally girls are like fingering
each other in the other room and
sitting on balloons and pop and blue.
They're like,
dude,
you've got like five hot chicks and the
other room like why aren't we in here?
Why aren't you watching the game?
Yeah. I might because their work,
their work and let them
work. Damn. You know,
she needs to buy some stuff and I don't
want to, I'm on paying for her hair.
It's 300 bucks for the fucking hair.
Fascinated by this was this was you,
you brokered sex tapes, right? Yes.
And some big ones. The biggest ones?
The biggest one of all
time. Was that, wait,
was that before you dated
girls in this industry or,
I was dating a bunch of girls and,
and um,
in fact when I first met
short and like in 99,
I was kicking it with this
porn star name Houston.
I remember it was a friend of mine and
she did the Houston six 20. She, yeah,
she fucked 20 guys on one day.
Well six 21,
six 22 would have made her a whore.
That's the way I looked at the way before.
I forget it was, it,
was it a marketing ploy?
I remember being sad when getting
it came out. And you're like,
this is the last APP. I was
like, he's going to retire. Yeah.
Is that marketing cause it's brilliant.
Yeah. It was just all, it was all numbers.
There was our marketing scheme
for that album was the, um,
the retirement. Yeah. Uh, what was
it with all of the media and stuff,
the announcement and then the party and
shit. And so you're like, oh, this is it.
And there was like, Oh shit, this
is what, at that time I had a,
that was my 10th album I remember.
And it is unheard of in hip hop.
Like nobody had 10 hours. Now you have
73 albums. Not about 2020. I don't know.
She's crying. He's got a new album
out right now called the pimp tape,
which is awesome. Awesome album.
It's also very educational.
It's like a reeducation. All right,
let me get that shit for sure.
Short threatened to, to, to be
tired like four different times.
And then he also threatened to get
married when he did marry married.
He didn't marry to the game album I got
married on hypothetically can look it up
right now. You only Internet. Yeah.
Google married to the game and it makes
a lot of sense. Shorts, the shorts.
A player for life too short.
Married to the game. Question.
What's the most common thing men uh,
buy when they buy a prostitute? What's
the, what's the thing you sell the most?
BJ's straight. I think you'd
have to ask her how. I never,
I never asked a whole what did you
do to late? They don't tell you.
I don't want to know. Yeah, that's true.
I really don't. Fair enough.
Wedding picture right there.
Yep. Yep. I never seen
that one over there.
Go Up to the right with the
two brides by themselves.
Go there.
That was a great wedding night.
Oh boy. What's the most women
you've had at once? Uh, four.
Four at the same time. Yeah. Yeah.
I never was into that thing where you
like bang a chick then like wash up and go
bang another chair. I never was
into that shit like four at once.
I was never into that cause I
like, I like the indulge. Yeah.
So if I'm indulging, it must be
something I'm really into. I don't,
I don't want that bang, get the fuck out.
And then looking around like I'm not,
I'm not a pervert like that.
But the night that I had the four chicks,
it was like,
I think they were all like rolling super
role and they were all feeling good and
shit. And, and uh,
we were in a hotel room and I was messing
with one girl and she told the other
girl it was good. What can
I try it? Yeah, it was good.
Then they like pass me around.
It pass you around.
I thought that I was doing it to them
until I thought back on it years later.
And I was like fuck to me. Yeah.
They, they ran a train on me.
They did poor man.
But you know,
shower with the water coming
down. Yes. Feel so used.
They argued over the last kingdom too.
I remember that Shit.
I argued over the last one. Who was
going to get that last bag? Man.
Do I have the same story to tell you?
So
those looks so in some
ways [inaudible] stories.
We all have old whole story, right? We
all only holding the room, you know,
I've got some old host.
Here's the nastiest of all them.
I was pretty nasty. Oh, stop.
You're married Ryan. Yeah.
Yeah. That's the best. Yeah.
So you've got to try to gift trader
old whole stories. So we have, yeah,
but he's Nastier than me.
Should I remember you were telling
is no standard that Puerto Rican,
I did love Puerto Rican.
Jesus cause you went like this.
How about the, how do you get settled
nurse sex tape and then become like,
alright, I can handle getting this out
there. How do you get the first one?
That's what I'm saying. Yeah,
that's a good story. So, um,
I had some friends that weren't allowed
to really be in the Internet business or
telecom business based upon some activity.
Just say they were wanted by some people.
They called
me up one day and said,
hey,
we got this tape of the social
ladder name's Paris Hilton and um,
we really want to put it out just like
our friend Seth did with the Pam and
Tommy Lee tape.
So I knew all these guys from back in
the day and I knew what kind of a debacle
that became to Pam and Tommy leaving.
And that was a scandal from the start.
It was like a scam. It was never stolen
and lost it just, well no, it was stolen.
It was that 100% was stolen out of their
house. It was stolen, make money of it.
They never made a dime. Okay. So that
was the standard of what not to do.
That was the standard of what not to do.
So some friends of mine in Seattle
who had learned through that said,
we know what to do with this,
but we can't put our names on this and,
and we want you to go out there and
publicize this thing for us. And I'm like,
well, what's the worst thing that
could happen? I'm a PR guy in the,
in the porn business and a,
this tape is interesting.
And I met with the guy who had the tape.
He was a roommate of this
guy in the brick Solomon,
who's now known as Rick of the Dick.
That's Rick in the, in the Paris team,
or as we call them,
the 50% copyright owner of the tape.
So rare in a time Rick was banging a
bunch of Hollywood was Shannon Doherty,
uh,
all sorts of like Hollywood people.
He was the guy who was on
the inside of all of this.
Can I ask you before you go further?
Did they make that with this
intent or was it made for fun?
Another good question.
So rigidly the lighting was pretty good.
It wasn't worth the original tape
was a green x ray vision tape,
if you remember correctly, when her
eyes are kind of glowing in the dark.
That was the tape that came
to us originally and was
not supposed to ever see
the light of day because we didn't
have the rights to put it out.
Paris had not signed off on it.
Rick in that signed off on it and all
we got was a bullshit story from Rick's
roommate who said he's got the rights,
he's going to do it for rec.
So we gave this guy $50,000 upfront
and Pam and the third of the back end
profits was our deal until I went
and sent two clips out to the media,
one to us weekly. And when the
entertainment tonight hell broke loose,
this is what became known as the very
first viral video because that got sent to
editors who sent it to their friends who
sent it to other people who made up the
title. That was a dump side
and one night in Paris.
I wish I could take credit for it.
I was like,
But Rick Solomon actually came
up with it with David Joseph,
the owner of a red light district video.
So we had the original tape.
I got sued for $10 million.
Did Paris consent to it being sold
at the time? At that time? No.
In fact,
and nobody actually knows this and I'm
going to tell you guys the story because
this is what we do.
Yes. Collusive. So, um,
everybody was suing everybody and people
were going online trying to find this
tape.
And there were literally $100 million
being made fraudulent by people saying
that they had the Paris Hilton sex tape
and their members area back then you
could join for $200 and see it and
they'd get in there and there was nothing
there. But everybody was using the rights
of publicity, which means that, you know,
too short is the only person in the
entertainment business that could use the
name too short.
That's his right of Tom Segura.
You're the only person who
could use the name Tom Guerra.
So using Paris Hilton or rex almonds name,
you'd be infringing on their,
on their mark.
And a lot of people were doing that.
So at one point when they were,
everybody was suing everybody,
Rick and Paris had a conversation
and they're like, look,
everybody's making money on this thing.
We should go back and make our own tape
and put it out there. And if you notice,
it's a very well lit. So they go back
and like this time we're shooting,
they go to the four seasons
in Beverly Hills. Wow.
And they shoot it and she gets final cut.
Cause you'll,
you'll notice in that movie
there's really no nasty cum shots.
There's no up close shots
of her vagina or her ass.
She did a cum shot in and the other one,
well there's a cum shot in it,
but it's not like there's a
full facial. Yeah, very boring.
But she did make the Dick, I know
she did. She made, she worked.
I should I should I put it in work.
I'm sure the four seasons loves,
this is funny.
As I told this to Harvey 11 years ago
and Harvey Levin put it on the TMZ bus
tour. So originally when it was going up
and down to the tail, when they go back,
yeah, we shoot it. She
has final cut. Right.
And then they give it to you and they're
like, here it is. They gave it to us, uh,
along with my brother who had now
gotten involved with this, with a,
with a web company up in San Francisco.
And we put up a hotel,
arris.com which was the only
legal place to put it out online.
And of course we, um, how
do you monetize it though?
People would join for 29 95 a month.
Okay. And they were buying DVDs back then,
you know, now it's just kind of pre
Kardashians. This is pre Kardashians.
This is pre porn hub. This is pre like
nobody paying for porn. It was a big,
it was a big window.
It's sold more DVDs than any other adult
movie in the history of adult movie.
Wow.
And it was a huge website for many years
and in fact it's still makes money all
these years later still makes money.
Not a lot of money,
but I mean if you go to porn hub people,
you know,
you could see the Paris
Hilton clip for free,
but now it's monetized by the traffic and
the advertising on there. Wow. So yeah,
that kind of, so you can still make money
from traffic on a, like a porn site,
like a free tube site. Yo. Yeah. Really?
People make money because you're,
you're buying clicks and you're actually,
you're monetizing it like, you know,
years ago in a niche website and it's
being like midgets, let's say, uh,
one in like 50 people looking for little
people online would buy and convert.
So that was good traffic. I heterosexual
site, maybe one and 200 back in the day.
Now because there's so many hits on porn,
have you got to like one in maybe
like 50,000? Well, Joel actually join.
Okay. If they're still convergence,
it's still converted to convert.
And the more specific you get in,
the more niche oriented you get,
the better off celebrities stacks.
They've always been the number
one driver on search engines.
Just the mere mention that there's
a sex tape out there of a celebrity.
People go and Google the gun yet with
Eco Bananas looking for that sex tape.
So how, I've heard stories
by the way, um, that,
that the Kardashians sex tape
was like very orchestrated.
Like as an idea
from the start,
like this is what we'll get
me to the next level. At first.
Kim Kardashians, as you know,
is a really good friend of Paris. And
she saw the phenomena happen, the Paris,
and she said,
I want to be big and famous too.
I don't want to just be some hanger on.
I'm going to put out my tape and
I'm going to leak it for free.
And that's when ray Jay came to me and
a friend of mine and we had a meeting
with him and he was like,
look,
you know she's wants to put this thing out
there for free. I'm like, no, no, no, no,
no, no. You guys could make lots
of money with this. And he's like,
well let's do this. And I said, well, let
me take you over to a couple of places.
So initially I wanted to
bring him over to a red light,
which is where we did
the one night in Paris.
And then I wanted to take him the vivid,
he kind of sidestep me.
He went to go see Joe Francis over at
girls gone wild who was best friends with
vivid. They kinda cut me out of the
whole thing. But again, I'm okay.
I ain't mad at it. You know, we all,
I'm still making money off sex tapes
all these years later cause people still
come to me with sex tapes. Wow.
Then you know, put them out now.
Now I make sure they go away.
People if you're a decent is more
money and making them go away.
Well it depends on the circumstance and
if you're a copyright holder, you know,
obviously if I steal your [inaudible]
sex tape to go when you're just going to
talk about,
so what do you think?
Making one so like I'm not
talking about one of the old ones.
I wish there was,
there's no Puerto Rican dare got doubled.
[inaudible] you guys can see
it and I'd love to see that.
If you guys did a double anal tape.
I'm pretty, yeah, I mean listen,
I'm pretty gross. Do you think?
No, we're both two children.
I'm 42 boobs aren't where they used to be.
You know what I mean?
This is exactly what
goes to swinger parties.
I look just like you stay
away from the boot. Cocky.
I wouldn't dream of it. Have you
been to a hockey party? Short?
Just found out that she was last week.
That's crazy.
Our radio show tonight that Arizona is
the most after they described it though I
recognize it from Japanese porn as soon
as some jet shit. I love that stuff.
They love it. It's a form of Japanese and
these points should be, I work criminal.
I worked for the comic one time
from Oakland who uh, you know,
I brought you up just like, you know,
we talked about music and he was like,
Oh yeah, I hang out with short
doc sometimes. I was like, really?
And then I asked him like, what's
that leg? He's like, I mean,
if you'd hang around with them long
enough, you'll get your dick sucked.
That sounds cool.
That's a true story that I can vouch for
more shorthand. Hung out with us more.
He got his dick sucked. Oh, that's great.
Yeah, I met short. We booked
him for a player's ball.
That was the name of our porn party
was telling you about it. Yeah.
And we had done it.
There's a place called the state palace
theater in New Orleans and we have told
the story a million times on our show,
but it was the weekend, the Bayou classic,
which is basically to black
colleges playing each other. Uh,
southern Mississippi and I
was at Grambling. Yeah. So,
um, needless to say, New
Orleans [inaudible] oh,
that's a high school, right?
Yeah, I think so. All
right. But needless to say,
New Orleans was very dark that weekend.
He was sent out to go play a party for
two black black brothers is what he
thought. My brother and I are
the black brothers. B, l a t, t,
O kb and d money k Bezel and d money.
That was our nom de guerre. Anyway,
he shows up at the state palace theater
and people are having sex on the dance
floor and there's a VIP rooms.
It was blow jobs going on.
He comes back and he looks at two white
boys dressed as pimps and I'm suited and
booted with like a biggie smalls hat.
I brothers in a red goes,
what is going on? And I came in. We're
so happy to have you here tonight. You,
I'm such a big fan of
yours cause just like you,
I grew up listening to two short course
and Cleveland I was bumping too short
from 1984 on. Yeah. So
um, yeah, he's like a,
all I know is I'm supposed to be planned
for two black brothers like no with a
black brothers, you know the
black brothers and he's like,
I thought you guys were black.
And I'm like why don't we kind
of are us us along with Lego.
And he looked at me cause
like I don't care man.
I don't care what you guys do and
what's going on, how can I be down?
Because there is people butt ass
naked out there. Penn House, pets,
porn stars. Yeah. So that
was my initial kickoff.
It was a great kickoff because we got to
what got him to play with kid Capri and
a slick Rick that night and
it was all my hip hop idle.
That's awesome man.
Back then I wasn't really
like participating in any
like AVN awards and none of
that shit.
And then you hear these guys come along
and they're like at the backstage passes
to the AVN awards.
Yeah.
We're like, sure, we want to book you
at the Playboy Mansion for a party.
He's like, I'm down. You know,
we had some good times,
so that's how we became friends.
I'm happy to say 20 years later and
I host a show with, with two shorts.
It's crazy. All the kb one nine these
chicks are like porn chicks. I like,
I wish I could just fuck a regular
guy right now. I'm like, man,
let me out the car. I
think you went in, right?
I maybe a little,
we had male challenge.
It didn't show up that night
and I'm cheap, so I'm like,
oh, hey, you know what?
Your wish is my command. Are
you in porns? No, no. Well,
not as far as you guys would.
Okay.
That means his dingalings been thrown
around and there's a thing called Pov.
Yeah, there's no pressure.
You don't feel the pressure.
Maybe now more because I'm 50.
I don't know if I would do it now,
but back then I was kind of out of my
mind. I had a good time back then. Short.
I want to ask you a question. So I
realized this like when we, when they,
when you said you're coming on,
I was so excited. And then I had,
I remembered that a while ago,
like maybe over a year ago I was on my
boy Hannibal Burress as podcasts handles
great comic Dj Tony Trimm.
Yeah. Randomly, I forget how we
got into it, but we brought up,
um,
blow the whistle,
the song and I realized that
in my memory I was like, oh,
I broke down.
What that song's about.
Like I was a professor teaching them and
then I realized that you were about to
come here. I was like, I don't really,
I don't know if I got it right.
I just decided that so can,
can we show it to you and you tell me
if I was accurate or not. That's go.
I liked,
by the way,
did you ever like really explore and at
the time I did and I'll just be honest,
the concept of blow the whistle,
it's actually pretty deep concept in and
of itself that he's a referee calling a
personal foul on you taking his
expression of that word. Right.
Like that's pretty, I didn't even catch
it. That's what, what the song was about.
So the song,
yeah,
blow the whistle is that he's a
ref basically blowing the whistle.
You're saying biatch the way he said
it, you're stealing from him, man.
He's coming from the
perspective of the referee.
He is playing a character whistle.
So he like,
he married is like that Dave Chappelle.
I'm proud of you man.
But like you're saying bitch, like I say
it and so are all these other bloating.
Yeah. That's a good way to
call somebody out. It is, man.
I got to fuck fucking up blow
whistle. That's pretty cool. Actually.
He doesn't get credit for that because
it's always getting his dick sucked.
How'd I do? Uh, you were on it Kinda. Huh?
But, um, it goes a little bit further
than that. Okay. Because I'm, once again,
if you just listen to the words,
it's actually I'm the ref and I'm blowing
the whistle on people who are doing
things they shouldn't be doing that. It's
not really the word bitch in the song.
It talks about doing too much drugs,
partying too much, staying up for days,
just doing shit that you shouldn't
be doing. And it's like, you know,
it talks about falling down hill and just,
you know,
just if you can't hang with the big dogs,
stay on the point.
You can't do this shit.
So cause you keep fucking up.
So it kind of goes in life in general.
If you see somebody fucking,
I've just blown, you know those west, so
hey man, oh the flag on them, you know,
and whatever the fuck I was almost
there you were, you were going up there.
I was like, is he gonna get it? Some
little kids told me it means suck my Dick.
Really? I didn't, that wasn't
my meaning, but it was like,
yeah,
I'm like suck my Dick.
I'm just saying, all right.
All right. Well cool man.
I'm glad to know that I almost got
it right. I had no idea. I just was,
I was owning the word bitch.
It was started,
it was starting to be an argument
out there of where it came from.
And Ryan overheard that argument
one day and somebody was saying,
not too sure I made this shit. Get
the fuck out of here. That shit go.
And they were logically
putting it all over the world
and shit. And I'm like, Nah,
I gotta I gotta own this. Yeah.
Cause you definitely, so it's,
it's cemented now.
There's no debuke no dispute,
no debate. It is solid,
too short said made it.
That's it. And I um,
you got to give a little
credit to Rudy ray Moore. Yup.
Cause I can take the old light to some
of his songs when he's in Dulla my
character.
Yeah.
And he's talking in the movies and on
some of his records and he goes bit.
Yeah. And he doesn't, I'm like me
and my wrap part in, back in the day,
we didn't get it from him per se. Yeah.
But he was one of our influences, so sure.
You know, indirectly that's
the, that's where it ended up.
So He's getting a little
credit too. Okay, thank you.
You're the one that's really, yeah,
that's, yeah, and then you know snoop dog,
when he got with death row, he does
demand, they adopted it and they kind of,
I give snoop the credit
for making it go so pop,
but I gave it to so many millions of
people and then he was one of the ones who
got it ingrained in him and he
passed it on to so many more million.
And then everybody,
I've seen comedians Duff's in old TV show.
It is embedded in pop culture.
I'm counting people go, you
should copy writing. Oh.
And I'm like,
no.
Do you have the button with you as soon
a trunk of a car that's in the trunk?
Hopefully. Yeah. Shorts.
Now marketing these buttons,
the bitch buttons you could find
on the short store.com oh yeah.
You basically hit the button and it says,
we got to get one of these. I said,
yeah. Now let me ask you about this.
I'm about to turn 40.
I'm trying to get it.
I'm a big hip hop jewelry with
something that chain, man.
Can you tell her where I can get one?
Um,
you've got to get jewelry for her
to call. Oh, for God's sakes. Um,
yeah. A lot of hip hop jewelers
out here. I feel like, uh,
that's a tough one, man. Cause I had,
I had different kinds of
jewelry for different kinds
of reasons. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
And the bling bling is, you've got
to have a purpose for you now. Yeah.
If you don't really have a purpose, it was
just like a waste of money. Like silly.
Yeah. Flashing and videos
and it's telling the story.
You told him not the show,
but he's fucking two short
baby. He needs the chain.
You're Tom Segura comedian. You
really fucking need a chain. Yeah.
Yeah. Pygmies, a famous rapper. Everybody
needs pimping tools. There you go.
Yeah. Right. Everybody needs to,
I don't know about everybody. Hi.
How am I going to get hosed
if I don't have nice jewelry?
Okay.
Literally though if you, if you rolled
up with some big rims on your car. Yeah.
As some Juriaan start spitting,
life would change. Yeah.
That's all you need for hose, but they
need to do, you wouldn't get nice ladies.
You'd get host. Yeah. Young at night. The
nice ladies don't. That's cool. I'm down.
Respond to that. How much, I
guess I'm just do the tractor.
Yeah.
What do you saying?
Have you seen him?
He never got to go back and research
some white pants. White pants. Get it.
We've seen it. I've seen
a documentary. Yeah.
Mr. White folks pose
that pose down iconic.
I think you could play Mr. White
folks. I'm close to it. Yeah.
Snoop used to call me Mr.
White folks when he's really,
he thought I was the guy that was
in there then. He's a white boys.
He thought I was the guy who was
a white boy cause he gave me that.
You were Mr. White. He give me
my nickname. The K Bezel. Yeah,
that sounds like it's, and then my
company man, getting out as a white guy,
getting a nickname from a black rapper.
It was after he won his adult a award
for doggy style where you guys haven't
been picture? Uh, this was actually
at a, uh, he had, what's it called?
He airbnb to place here in la. Okay.
So he was like, he was Hannibal.
Hannibal was like, fuck hotels.
I remember he was like, yeah,
I don't like smart everybody, you know,
I know where I'm staying. Hate that guy.
Single handedly brought bill Cosby down. I
realize that. Right. Well, I mean, he got,
he, he, you know, he was actually
just doing a bit at, uh, he got shot.
He got in trouble. They got
mad at him and he said, God,
I'm mad at him for just saying like,
just somebody crazy elite,
like not supposed to be recording. Right.
You know, just records. It puts it out.
And then that whole people were like,
oh yeah, start started. You know.
And that's why they have the yonder
bags now when Chappelle plays. Yeah.
Got locked those phones away. No Shit
is crazy for me. Ask you something.
You don't think, if you could find
a nice lady who took care of you,
cook for you to, he could wifi up
like, would you ever wife a lady up?
I've been in relationships not
devoid of relationship. What?
When's the last time you had one?
Um,
I'm always the one
really.
I mean like a serious,
like seriously.
They're all serious.
Oh my God.
Why is there no real love
and your future in my past,
present and future there
is what I'm telling you.
You can't not a fucking superhero.
You gotta you gotta have it.
You've got to have love of course.
But I mean,
is there a mrs too short
in the future desk? Put it
like this. The w the women,
women in my life understand what
I do for a living and you know,
it's the, don't let the music
persona distort the reality. Okay.
It was a hard on there. All right. I know.
I want to see him when they got
to do on Christmas. I don't know.
Just fuck all a Santa has
reindeer isn't shit. No,
he stopped being a player right
around them. Right when it gets cold.
Yeah. And then you start back
up like right around now.
Right, right. Yeah, that's true.
I think my dad did the same shit.
That's when he would bring some girl
around and like here's your new mom.
And I'm like, yeah, I know.
Oh he would have been a good pimp and
then come spring no more mom. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. No. Yeah, totally. Dude.
He could teach a seminar numbers.
He's got numbers cause he gets a bitches
used to clean his house forum and do
all kinds of stuff.
Pretty solid. Yeah. Yeah.
Really knew how to mute. There's a lot
of ways to go wrong with the shit too.
Like I know a guy who I am,
I know a guy who was fascinated by the
look of it and just the idea of it.
So he went to an older pimp
and he said teach me the game.
And the outer pimp was like flattered.
He was like,
cause he know the guy had
to look, you know he, yeah,
he was playing the part but he
wasn't, it wasn't really any, yeah.
So the Oda [inaudible],
he's like,
well this is what you gotta do any like
really schooled him for like a long time,
like two fucking years or some shit.
And this guy figured it out,
but he did one thing wrong.
The first how he ever
had was his girlfriend.
Oh. And they had been together
and they were like taking in,
absorbing all these pimp talking shit.
And they're like, yeah, we got to do this.
So what happens is
she started working,
she liked it.
She liked how he as some point was like,
you know,
realizing the dark side and and realizing
really inside him that he wasn't about
that. Now he loves his woman. He
loved her before they started this.
And he's like,
in his mind trying to get her
to take a turn with him, like,
let's do something different. She's like,
fuck, noticed the money. It's that shit.
So she literally got to the
point where she was like,
will you go if the crushing it
crushing, yeah, he went from,
from good kid to pimp to like church boy.
Wow.
He went straight to the church. I
get there. It does it t you could,
you could and you could get ended up
in situations where you saw called
controlling these women and things
happen to them and that, that guilt,
you can never get over that shit. No.
That's when you go straight to the church.
Hey, you go out there and say, I got
away. I get that money and that baby,
she never comes back everyone life
ever again. Like whoops. Yeah.
And his father is that,
but luckily white pimp
hoes out there. So I be
like, she's dead anyway.
Now let me ask you this because you are
of too short too is you can sing two
shirts. I don't see a woman. Yeah. And
then kind of it, but kind of know. Yeah.
Maybe I'll singing this
song. Suck my fucking, yeah.
You think I haven't heard some of
that shit. Come on man. What is,
what is okay? You've
been, you've been okay
this long, all this success. What's the
dumbest Shit you've ever bought? Oh,
I love this question. That's
a great question. I'm dying
to know this to myself.
Yeah. Um, I think, um,
I had a one time, the first time
I ever negotiated for a big check,
I remember, uh, the check
arriving and it was a,
it was going to come in increments,
like four checks to a total of
about like 2 million. All right.
So I figured they were going to
come quick to, cause it was like,
we don't want to give you
all this money in one day.
We'll give it to you over like 90
days or some shit like that. So
the first one came and logically knowing
that there are more coming, I'm like,
I'm fucking this one up. Yeah. So
literally I just, it's just dumb.
Should I could ever think of
it started,
it was probably like 97 and it started,
um,
like in one week,
I think I bought like 150,000 on a car,
about a fucking hundred
thousand dollar boat.
Went by two fucking jet skis
with a truck to pull him whoa.
And a truck for the boat. Yeah.
And fucking I'm, it was just like,
it was a spending spree of, of,
you know what? This was the logic.
You know what? I've been making
this money and living his life,
doing all this good shit. This one
time I'm just going to fuck it all off.
I didn't do it a lot in life,
but that one time I fucked it off.
And about two years later I went on
a good roll too cause I was like,
oh that new beamers out. Oh I don't know
shit. They made the special edition. Oh,
so about two years.
I was like,
I thought I was like this baller dude who
knee and hip hop was kind of preaching
that shit at the time.
That was just the bad boy videos and the
bling bling air and everybody was like
platinum jury and diamonds
and all this shit.
And people were spending $1 million
on videos and shit. It was, yeah,
it was just out of hand and out of
control and hip hop. So I woke up, um,
it was 1999 and all the talk was y two k
y two k the possibly shit could happen.
The computers aren't going to reset.
They're gonna reset when they're not
supposed to lie. The stupid y two k right,
right. Yeah. Well it's
going to end that night.
1999 in 2000 comes in like
half a bottle of water,
have everything ready to go.
So it was 1999 the world was about to
end and I looked out in my driveway one
morning I woke up,
I had a big ass fucking house with
like a driveway that you could,
it was like a three car garage,
but the driveway can hold like another
15 cars and walk outside my house.
There's three cars in the garage and
he's like eight cars in the driveway and
they're all mine. I'm like, I'm like,
I spent everyday taking one of these
fucking cars to the shop to get the stereo
fixed to the rim. It's rims fucking
rotated or the guy does this.
It was just so much shit at,
it was that moment.
That little two year period I just
realized you stupid motherfucker like you
really ended up with eight
cars. I just one driver. Yeah.
And I've never done that shit. Aye.
It was like a fire. So I even um,
at that point something
really great happened cause
it was this whole end of the
world, Shit, I am 2000 kicked in
the world didn't end and I was like,
damn,
you got to do something spectacular.
So I told like a bunch of
my closest personal friends.
I was like everything fucked up.
Last year I fucking lost
every fucking dime I had.
I think I'm about to lose my fucking
house. I'm fucked. I'm fucked.
Because I used to be the guy who
would always take everybody to,
but everything's,
I mean we go out and just everything
and make sure it might make money.
I just wanted to, I was,
it was an experiment.
I was only going to do it for like six
months or something and I just like I
just told everybody for a lot.
I,
I was in the house organizing music
files and doing some personal,
you know, Shit. I had all this
music, all these files, all his shit.
I think MP three s were new.
I was converted all my shit.
The MP three and I just really liked was,
I thought the world was going end,
so I really, I was like, I got a
little free time on my hand, the world.
And then so I played this
trick and guess what?
Probably about like 95% of my
friends just quit calling. Really?
Yeah.
It was like be in this industry.
You kind of know that you
have acquaintances and you
had friends and I still
have the same friends I had
since fucking high school.
So that just tells you you this shit.
But I just wanted to see people when
people say Shit like this, you give a guy,
I'm a $25,000 check for some shit.
He didn't music.
He's the guy who never had money like
that 25,000 you already bro. He goes, man,
I fucking love you. I will
fucking, anything you need.
I was killed somebody for you and I,
that was always my like red
flag and somebody says, go
kill something. I'm like,
no, that's not what the
check is for it. But, but um,
as soon as that money's gone, I was like,
they're like, yeah, like you got 25 more.
He like, Nah, they was the only earning
25. Like, well fuck you then man. Yeah.
It's just, it's just funny like
that. So yeah. So um, yeah, that was,
it was an eye opener. I've never had
eight cars at the same time since then.
I don't take on a lot of fucking close
circle personal friends and you know,
yeah. Smart. You're in the circle
k mart. I'm in the circle. Yeah.
I'm very fortunate. He has not
be traded my field yet. Not yet.
And how did you guys,
oh,
so how'd you hook up to like where did
the idea to come to do the radio show?
Well, I was um, another good question. Ah,
rolling stones doing a feature on me
that's supposedly coming out next month.
It's all about the me too. It's all
about fixing. A long time ago, man.
We did. We can, we talked to
her like what, eight months ago?
So it's been taken a little while,
but it's finally coming out. Uh,
I brought Amanda the writer down to meet
short downtown cause I thought I'd give
her a little cross section of some
of the people I deal with. You know,
I fucks with a lot of people.
So she was so blown away by two short
and she was like, this is great.
What nice guys. What a
great facility. Shorts.
Got a place downtown called the boombox.
It's about a 30,000 square foot facility
and every really, really rough 15th.
That was crazy. 15. I'm sorry.
This is like, just where you work.
It says my thing. It's my thing.
It's this compound he's got,
he's got a giant studio downtown.
Yes. That's painted like a boombox.
And the uh,
the middle where the cassette would be
is the actual window into the studio,
but he's got different rooms.
Got a barbershop in there.
He's got him. And there's,
there's recording equipment in every room.
So if you're inspired,
you know he's got artists down there
that are working in every single room.
That's the factory hit factory. So
anyway, I brought down the writers,
she loved it and she started
saying something about a
podcast and shorts, like,
you know,
we should really do a podcast together
again because we did one last year,
a couple of years ago when he did
it and it was really a fun time.
He had snoop and ice cube and Chanel
west coast and a bunch of cute bash.
You were on the Chanel show. Yeah,
that was, that was, that was an,
that was kind of like the green
light for me was that we had big,
big, big names on the show.
Russell Simmons and I mean it just,
the list went on and on.
Actors sports player and
the Chanel and kb shell,
Chanel west coast from ridiculousness.
Yeah, that was the highest rated show.
Yeah. So I ended up being on the
highest rated show, but it was,
I enjoy this because he's says shit like,
what the fuck did you say on that show?
Who knows? Probably told about just sex
stuff. Yeah. You say shit. He's like,
he's like, um, we just having a normal
conversation like this and then kb goes,
yeah. Like when Kim Kardashian
got peed on the original tape,
she was getting paid on. What's your
really, Rachel was every in honor.
Ray J denied and Kj denies it.
But I know what I saw while we were just
talking about Chuck Berry's video today.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah, he does.
Before Kelly farts, like
as she's blonde, he's like,
he's like did our far and she's like,
yeah. He's like, yes, sometimes I do that.
Maybe aren't Kelly saw that shit and you
get maybe I'm like a mitten mentor kind
of thing going on through possibly.
Possibly. Yeah. I mean, look,
there's a lot of sex tapes out there
that you know about it. All right,
let's talk about the sex tapes.
We don't know about.
Kb is a, he's a cold brother, you know,
he does what's up. He's
like, look at this shit.
And he shows me his phone. I
show him painting, all kind
of people you know, doing,
Ugh, why sex? I mean,
years ago I showed short a video clip of
Justin Bieber singing a song with the n
word in it and I got out that guy,
he had purchased it five different times
and spent hundreds of thousands to make
it go away.
When he was 16 he finally had to just
fess and I showed it to shorten shirts
like that career is done
and we all thought he'd be
done someone's lyrics or was
this his own?
He had a song called one less lonely
girl and he was like one less lonely
inwards.
One lesson he wrote it.
He was just like trying to get a reaction
out of his white friends and they're
all laughing along with them,
but it was not nice.
And granted he was a kid are back to
the sex tapes back to the sex tapes for.
So uh, no,
no.
I'll tell us why.
I've signed a lot of NDA so I can't
talk about some of them. Yeah.
But I will say that the Tom Sizemore tape,
which did come out eventually,
it was probably one of the most
disturbing tapes I've ever seen.
Movies or something.
Say selling.
So somebody from this movie
and somebody from that movie,
Tom Sizemore had the priapus zoom,
which is when you have a hard
on for longer than four hours,
that's what they warn you against,
like blink once or twice.
Um, that was a bad way, I
would say. Uh, okay. So I'm,
but why was it a bad one?
Tom Size?
But it was bad because he was high on
crystal meth and he had five hookers in
the Chateau Marmont and he's talking
to the camera and he's just glazed and
you're like, well, I feel bad for this
guy. Yeah, no, it didn't link up it,
it actually came out commercially vivid,
put it out for a little while.
It wasn't five hookers. Yes, Jesus man.
I had the Collin Farrel sex tape as well,
which was a really interesting tape.
That really, yeah, with Nicole
and rain, she was one of the,
a seven black playmates and the history
of playboy. But when I first saw it,
I was actually a friend
Nicole. Me, she's cool. Uh,
I was actually taken in the trunk of a
car because these guys didn't have wide
in the back. So you were on the
trunk of a car before? Yeah.
This guy's calling me up. They're
like, Yo, you're hands free. Yeah,
but I was just going up sunset plaza
because they didn't have room in their
Honda to get me up there.
But I was such a horror.
One guy kidnapped in a Honda
from Mel's drive ever kidnap me,
kidnap me and something better.
Nice man.
Better be a chord like 2019 and
core trunk space, man, they um,
they put me up to this house.
I got a little string in there.
You can let yourself up.
I wasn't really worried cause they wanted
one point $2 million for the sex tape
and they knew I was the only guy that
was going to be able to get it for him.
So when I actually went into this house,
it just kind of back like
then like sorta like relaxed.
Like when I got in the House I was like
this for a second. I mean the Trump was
even shot. Did you call your brother? No,
I called him right after this all
happened by the ride. Just got to trunk,
trunk right now. I drove up from San
Diego. I was living in Carlsbad trunk.
Yeah. Great. Great. Two
short songs by the way. Yeah,
in the trunk feature in blessed cancer
featured in the opening scene was like
big deal. Big Deal. Big check in
the trunk is cracked. So yeah,
I was going to try some frilliest
kidnappers. Yeah, for real.
I ended up going into this,
uh,
Manchin and they put the VHS tape in and
there's Colin Farrell, it really a kid.
And I said get in the trunk
cause we don't have room for you.
They said we weren't really planning on
showing it to you and we don't have room
in the backseat of our car, but we don't
want you following us up in your car.
So when will you agree to get blindfold
them and put in the trunk of the car?
I left out the blind fold is a Bandana.
So, uh, you can't know where we ask.
So you want me to go on where I was going.
So I went up,
it was literally three and
a half minutes to the house.
I now recognize it was sunset plaza
that I was going up. Right. Windy road,
cause I wasn't living in La at the time.
I go in there,
they put the VHS tape in and there he is,
the shaved head naked with the biggest
penis I've ever seen in my life for a
little guy. Who's that? Collin Collin.
And he looks at the and goes, go,
I could do this for fucking breakfast.
Fucking lunch and fucking dinner.
I can eat that kitty.
And I'm like,
and he's got a cigarette dangling from
his mouth and his holy a Guinness.
I'm like, if this isn't my tripod
off dude, this guy, I was like,
does he breathe through this thing family?
Her camera was flying.
She was filming it with, with her handheld
camera. Okay, okay. And I'm just going,
Holy Shit. This is amazing. I knew her
at the time that that was a scandal.
She was like, I'm about to be rich. Yeah.
She really didn't get paid to work and
make money from this. Now we shut it down.
Um, oh he, he wanted it to be shut down.
He had to pay a lot of money for it to go.
Really?
It didn't go to her,
did not go to her because you
were talking about like, you know,
having rights in the copper. Why
does, so how does it work if like,
if you're the person in it, who are
you paying to make it go away? So why?
So let's say, um, you're going through
an airport, you guys travel a lot,
you've got your laptop on one of those
little things going through Tsa and you
get held back or whatever and all of
a sudden somebody makes off with your
laptop. Okay? Somebody gets into your
laptop. They tried to put out this tape.
They can't put it out legally
because if they're not on it,
you and Christina are the only two
people. Yeah. Okay. In a sex tape.
She's a 50% copyright holder. Europe,
50% copyright holder. Right now,
if I get ahold of your computer,
I might have possession of your computer,
but I don't own your computer.
Right.
Which makes me in possession
of stolen material. Right.
Which is how we shut down 90% of them.
If you don't have the right to publicity
and you don't have the rights from at
least one of the people and even one
of the people's problematic because you
need to have both of the people.
So in this scenario though,
let's say we use your scenario. Yeah.
So then it's like, so Tom, you know,
Kevin's got it or whatever. Um, and
I don't want it to get out, right.
Am I just paying you to
give me my laptop bag?
Or what you're doing is you're basically
hiring me to go out there and that the
person that has it,
I'm going to find out how they got it,
what their intention is with it.
And 90% of the time, you know,
we now live in this TMZ world
where people want to go and they,
they feel this is newsworthy. Oh,
Tom Segura, he's a huge comic.
We're going to put this out as a story.
He's got a sex tape being
sold around the valley. Well,
Thomson Guerra might have a deal with
Disney coming up and you probably in the
next shaggy dog and you don't need that
because you're going to get $2 million
picture. Pretty cool. Porn said you
guys have, by the way. Thanks man.
Does look very poor. Very poor.
They could do some good thoughts.
This neighborhood's very poorly,
by the way.
I could tell you stories about what
goes Forney. Yeah, that's Porny.
Um,
but yeah,
so what we'll do is you would actually
me alongside with your lawyers, we would,
uh,
coordinate getting this stuff back to
you and make sure that there's no copies.
Is that money being paid going to you
and the lawyers or also that guy who just
so he needs a pay off? Well, they
go away when you pound. Okay.
You know their horse too.
And later on that people who'd
tried to bravely put them out,
it's just a boring most,
the most part, right? Nobody
really made money like Paris.
Yeah.
I will say this.
Another exclusive and why image and shit.
Hold on.
This is a wire may check exclusive.
So exactly a year ago,
last week I was shocked.
A woman calls me up and she's like, do
you have a secure line for me to talk to?
Right. Like I'm like in the
cone of silence or something.
I'm like, okay, yeah.
It's like I get on a whatsapp call with
her and I'm like, what do you have?
She says,
a guy sent me a tape of this model
slash actress for years ago and she is
tossing a salad and
it's, you know, oral sex.
Yes, eat the scrum. And I said,
great. How do you know this guy? Well,
he's a photographer, he's
based in Florida. I was doing
some stuff with them. Okay.
And who's the person we're talking about?
And she was beating around the Bush
and beating around the bush. I said,
who is the person we're talking about
here before I call my lawyer and get
anybody involved in this,
you have to tell me.
So then she says her name is Megan and
she's about to marry a prince and he
get his story not true to it is true.
I'm going to show you the
email communications and
you'll see why picture of it
Brunette second and Dick
from the top of her head.
I'm here to tell you that I believe
you believe. Is that correct?
Your assumption where in my opinion I
believe this is bagging and you believe
she's,
she's eating this again.
I know what I saw is just treat and when
I reached out to the lawyer and I told
him, look, this is what's going on,
she and the change the diaper guys,
we're going to say allegedly or his legs
pulled up like he's going to change his
diaper and you can't see
her until I seen the shit.
He saw one still photo but I saw him
show us the shit bro. Saying your phone.
I don't have it. She's
a lady. I got rid of it.
Case Interpol or am I six or if
you're listening it is now gone. Yeah.
This is not in my phone. If
anyone's listening. Kevin's got it.
The woman in Canada who called me,
how's it? Damn. Anyway, so yeah,
that's the kind of setup razor.
It's gonna snitch are out there like that,
but there was another
time I will say this.
Can I tell the story about when
you told about some guy calling me?
You give somebody my number, the amount
of sex that you can say his name. Okay,
well he's not going to
see us anytime soon.
He might hope that he calls me
up one day. He goes, hey man,
I gave your name to a friend of mine. He's
got a sex tape. I'm like, oh, okay, cool.
Cool. He's, he's going to
be calling you. I'm at bed,
bath and beyond with my ex
fiance shopping for curtains.
I see that number pop up. I
answered the phone. Hayes's KB.
Yeah. It shook. Excuse me. I'm like,
I can't hear you.
It's really loud in here.
It sounds like you're saying it's sugar.
It should ne Patsy was my brother
fucking one man. I'm like, the money.
Come on man. What's your fucking fucking
with me for it? And then I realized, wait,
my brother wouldn't know, shook
night's call me. And then he goes,
I'm Todd's friend. Well, two shorts,
real name as you know. Of course,
touch on. That's when I
realized, Oh fuck short.
Gave my number to checkmate.
So then he proceeds to tell me what he
has and he's got a tape of a very famous
rappers wife who was not
with him. And I'm like, dude,
this is not something you want to put out.
Honest to God,
we can't put it out legally. And I'm
trying to teach shook night about the law.
And he's like, well fuck that. I'm putting
this thing out. This is how much money?
Hello? Hello. No, yes,
with the, oh honey, Noah.
I that came to me a couple of times back
when the Oscar de la Hoya stuff started
happening too. And that's am my
rolling stone article. By the way,
Jay Jay Lo had a sex tape with her
first husband, the guy by the name of,
oh honey Noah. That was shot many years
ago, and they shut that down as well.
So that never came up. But
the one that shook, they did,
he end up putting it out and
now that one never came out. Um,
but for two days it was pretty hairy
and I was like, I had to say no to him.
I couldn't get involved with them.
Oscar, I want to wait to write.
Oscar de la Hoya has had three
different things. Shop does it? Yeah.
Shit out there. He's got shit out
there. But the first couple of things,
he was in a women's leggings and stuff.
I've seen that photo upside down and oh,
that was in that photo.
Yeah. Well the last thing,
I got the wedding dress thing with the,
yeah,
he was at a wedding dress the second time,
but this third time,
a couple of months back,
somebody came to me of the tape and
he was running around his apartment in
Pasadena and he's got, um, he's got a way,
not a location because the hookers said
that they came off a seeking arrangement
to his place and he was out of
his mind and po hit a big problem.
Huge problem. He's running around
and he's got a whisk in his rectum.
Okay. Yeah. And they have an idea
with a whisk is, oh, it's because
he's got the handle of it and he's running
around out of his mind and the girls
are videotaping this. And I'm like, oh
my God, this poor guy. Granted, you know,
whatever.
And then he puts a,
another like a spatula handle up there
and they're playing and rough it.
And I'm like, oh my God, devil.
And all I'm thinking is I,
if I'm some chick, I'd be
more worried about sleeping
over at us. Can still fight.
Right. Yeah. I know. And he's got a
lot of money. Any from La Program,
I'm more afraid of that mother fucker
cooking me breakfast in the morning cause
I don't wanna get pink guy, you
know? But uh, yeah. That was, um,
it was an extortion
attempt. Oh, it was? Yeah.
Side of the hose by the hose and the
FBI got involved and I ended up meeting
with the FBI and the,
the writer was from rolling stone was
with me when I showed up to meet with the
feds.
And the feds flipped the fuck out there.
Like what are you doing bringing in
a writer with you? I'm like, well,
she's fought with me
dude. So did, did they,
are they like prosecuting those girls?
They prosecuted the girls
attracted down by Florida.
Sometimes I get involved with
law enforcement of serious
shit. I like to turn my,
uh, my powers towards the good.
I seem to La Jolla pose. Yeah.
That picture with the leggings and
the heels. Kb caught me one day.
He's like this chick that you know,
oh,
is involved in a really big scandal
with the football players by,
can you do me a favor? Call her right
now and tell her, shut the fuck up.
Yes. Just chill. Shut up and don't say
shit. And she just ran her mouth. Ran Him.
I ran mouth. Yeah, man, that's the
problem with the loud. No, no, no, no, no,
no. This is the problem
with the me two generation.
There's a lot of girls that actually
have legitimate gripes. You know,
when you're talking about wine scene,
you're talking about stabbing me
to Jenner ration. Well, but it's,
it's a movement.
It's a movement.
So there's a lot of girls now that
don't have like significant claims,
but you want to become famous.
Sure.
This started with the tiger woods things
years ago there were two girls that
actually had sex with tiger woods.
17 ministers has come out of nowhere.
So everybody wants to be famous.
Everybody wants to be like too short.
That's right. Any talent
to do that? Yeah. Yeah.
Well that's what I used to see
guys that pimp names. Yeah. Yeah.
Christina pee. You're a pimp. You could
just go buy a girl. Oh yeah. See? Oh Shit.
Now I just need to get the chain.
And then you have a female Pam.
You'd be Christina P. Yeah, for real. I
could keep that as my pimp name too. Yeah.
We, that's what we call
parents. We calling p.
Are there any lady pimps?
Yeah,
column Madams and ladies is pimps too.
There's a movie out right now.
Um, um, it was my girl's name.
She was on the show to a Kiki
Palmer. Oh, kicky Paul. Oh,
Heidi Fleiss. She was a very famous
matter. I was at a movie, I'll call Pam.
She's a pimping the movie. Oh she
emailed the new movie Netflix on Netflix.
I guess I, I've, I just imagined
madams to run like a house.
Like you usually see that in a, you know
the bunny ranch and suicides of Shit.
Yeah, I don't you don't see
them on the streets. Yeah.
There's a lot of girls. The
saloon, you don't see no streets.
The pimping on the web, there's
a lot of escorts. Oh cool.
Well so women are getting too,
you can send a special shout out because
you seem to be, you seem to be like um,
like your, you care. I
care about these holes
you do care about. You know, I just
economics and shit cause I, you know, um,
I don't get it. I was going to let the
renegades, right. What's the renegades?
Those are the hosted refused
to have pimps. I like, okay,
so you that you can see now I'm into that.
Those are independent subcontractor.
Yeah. Cause here's the deal.
And the same with porn.
I just feel like we should make money
off of it. It's just the, I just get it.
I uptight about the money,
like my favorite hole is that right?
The Ivy League hose. Ivy League
coach. I've read a book by a bed.
She said that she was an ivy league Google
Ivy League hose. No, and there's a girl
and she was that and she, she's a
British lady and she claims that she,
I had a great life and I
became a prostitute and it
was great and blah blah blah.
Ivy League escorts have Ivy
League degrees. No Shit.
And you got to pay them money to fucking
date then like a 50 grand weekend or
something. What? No boy
eat it from behind Ivy League.
Super baby sugar baby.
Yeah. Okay. Okay.
You can get into that and you
have to go lunch. Can't be a hoe.
It's not in me man.
It's
so go back and look at the actual
websites where you can like go find these
bitches.
I released escorting and skip the games.
Escort Ivy League companion, skipped
the Games. Scabs the games guys.
She can get it. What she
wants. She doesn't look like
fucking Ivy League whore.
I'm going to say, how do
you know? Did they have,
did they have to bring their
transcripts to the date? Yeah,
in spring term papers, if you're
looking for an intellectual experience,
it should be instantaneous. You should
know like near a night. You better.
No Way. Real Ivy legally if she goes. No,
I went to Vanderbilt here fucking out
of here cause I not tonight harbored top
10 schools only fucked by Yale Brown
shit.
This became popular during 10 or
so years ago during a recession.
Oh really? Yeah. You and let you
pretty girl degree broke his foot.
Yeah, makes sense. Oh rich motherfucker
need somebody to go to Greece with him.
That's right. Yeah. You would never do it.
Now I'd rather be broken a gutter probably
wouldn't even have like good. Okay.
Let's just say you had a Tuesday
boyfriend. It's Tuesday today. Sue there
every Tuesday you come to his office.
Okay.
And he's still on his desk.
I mean fucking eat your pussy
or something. I don't know.
He's like old executive dude.
Okay.
Every first of the month he
wears you like 25 grand. Come on,
let me ask you this. Is
there a business? Let's talk.
Is there a business where I can just
fart in his face or kick him in the nuts
and I don't have to let him
touch me? Yes, there is actually.
That's the kind of shit, that's what
I was nine to five dominant trends.
You can go right down the street
somewhere. Me Mother fuckers part time,
part time. Tom would be okay
with that. That's fine with me.
You forgot to say I want
to see them checks? Yeah.
Could you teach him to teach him
how to get the pimp hand strong?
Teach him some sayings. Pimps always
had them give me some sayings. I get.
What do you, how do you motivate?
Let's say I don't want to work tonight.
I don't care right tonight.
Oh,
I liked that. I liked that a lot on the
right train you on the wrong track. Ooh.
If you knew better,
you'd do better.
Is that what you say I want to do
was I don't do fancy Saint Barts. No,
no. I just do logic. He's like, in
Memphis, my approach is mathematics.
I'm tired. I don't want to work
tonight. I, I'm real tired. Okay.
Just work Christmas. We'll take tonight.
I've worked, they work Christmas though.
While you're saying it's good
logic, you got it all right.
One day or another. You know
you want Christmas off. You
want to take tonight off.
I'm not, I'm not taking you
to the pip and whole ball,
but I've been looking
forward to that all year.
Hey, calms the girl bitch, Bitch,
bitch. They like that or do they
get offended or they get upset?
You can't say bitch.
You can call the girls.
You can't say my name.
I remember those documentaries taught
me his daddy about bottom bitches and
who's your bottom? But do you have a
bottom? But did you have a bottom bitch?
I never got into it like that.
I'm giving you scenarios. I never,
I never had to make so much
fucking money. I wrap. I hear Ya.
When I did dabble and I
dabbled because it came to me,
I didn't go looking forward
and I'm like, okay, somebody,
somebody says I'm going to give you all
this money every day. You don't say no.
You realize how,
how strong it has to be,
but like you're not trying
to get into pimping hoes.
Like here's money. Thank you.
I know babies too short though.
Alright.
Imitates life cycle. Never ending.
You put it out there, right?
You put it out there and it comes back.
So player born American,
your bottom bitches, your
favorite, the queen's favorite.
Hypothetically it is,
uh,
the most solid one and a crew
who is the most trustworthy. Ooh.
Sometimes has seniority and who you know,
either has the temperament and
the skills to cope hemp with you.
Oh Wow. So she's even elevated above.
She kind of helps you in business.
You should like three weeks and you
know, bottom bitch, hold it down.
You're kidding. I did not
know that. Cured the bag.
The money's there and damn,
everybody's still happy.
And I'm telling you, we should
really get into it. Get into process.
Here's the thing, Joe Movies about that
and it doesn't end good. Oh, I know.
Now is the best thing going.
And this might be a stupid question,
but I'm assuming I'll be live on this
hypothetical. Okay. So,
so I'm assuming you, it's a cash business.
You don't take a fucking credit card.
Wait, Twitter. I've been
seeing documentaries about
this shit. We'll watch the,
the p four watch the budget's Keith
a terrible at, I'm a hole lock.
It sounds got to it.
Is it hardest fight?
So I don't understand why everyone
was a fucking stuck. Okay. Okay.
So Lipski cause Jetski so, so you
get up ski, it's a cash business.
You appeasing Sam's has
Europe, pimps, pimps, Getsky,
Penske, Penske, MC. So you
get, it's a cash business,
but you can't put the fucking
cash in the bank. What do you,
you know what I'm saying?
Where do you,
where do pimps put the cash
in the mattress? Credit Union.
What do you mean credit unions
take that kind of money. Oh, okay.
But pibs that's in the mattress.
Yeah. Yeah. Come on. It's like, ah,
I got to figure that part
out. See, everybody knows, but
he's like, I'm not telling,
yeah, I saw him get real uncomfortable.
You can have that conversation.
Camera's going, hey, so
where's, where's your cash?
[inaudible] not you.
I see a hybrid.
So it ended the lining of
jackets and shit like that. Um,
I don't know what you would do. I really
don't. Hey, can we do a show together?
You might live on stage. Yeah. Like
I'll do a set and then you do a set.
You close it out. That'd be amazing. You
stay on the show and then you come out,
blow the doors off with some,
you know with the hits man.
We'll do blowjob, Betty.
Yeah. Oh, the wait. We got
to do it without the dissolve
part. I'll fucking do.
What was that line again?
I said bus left and up right now in a job.
Spur him on the cheeks. It's all dissolved
instead of all she saw. I fucked it up.
It's all dissolved salt. Oh no man. She
rubbed it in. It would never dissolve.
We should thought that. Yeah, I
know. I should have thought about it.
She gets sticky. It's still, you still
see it. It's still there. Is that right?
Is there like years
later it's still there,
but the thing is still in her dead
ass. Fucking Betty's throat. Mike,
what does she look like?
Can you describe her?
I always picked her like Betty
rebel from the Flintstones,
but that's not accurate.
Just loosely all the have Elizabeth.
What does that mean? Just he's just
a girl next door. Yeah, just a girl,
but she brunette.
I haven't really dealt with a lot
of hookers that look like hookers,
you know what I mean? Oh, okay. Like
literally like gate girls turn bet. Yeah.
Ooh, she's a good girl. Good look
at hose. Okay. All right. Let's, um,
let's say it again,
the show.
You guys are doing a blow the whistle
dash radio dash radio and the new album,
it's called the pimp tape. Pimp
tape. And it is everywhere.
You want to look for it. It's
everywhere. Very educational.
He's got a huge rappers and he just
maybe not contemplating doing a g rating,
educational and music. Really? Why? Just
because that music is so infectious. Yeah.
That I'm thinking we're in a time and
day now where different learning tactics,
you know, I like it. I'd be an experiment,
but what do you rap about though when
you're g rated? Just like anything.
Just Electric Company Shit. Yeah. Okay.
Sesame Street Shit, you know? Yeah. Yeah.
We love sesame street.
Did you guys have to hear some titles of
songs off the new album lab? Definitely.
It starts off with go short dog.
Yeah. It goes into break a bitch.
That's the second track and then
tables featuring snoop dog bring bitch.
The Hook is, are you a pimp or a Hoe?
I'm like that. Which one are you?
Ain't my girlfriend.
My girlfriend is my favorite track and
this is the best music video that you'll
ever see. By the way, you'll have to
Google that one. The videos for him.
Funny track number five is
give her some money. Hey,
I like that you're talking about
strippers, strippers. It's still,
they're getting money. No,
strippers is around money.
Truck six is save all that love.
He goes,
well you work for your boyfriend for the
boyfriend because daddy don't need it.
How to be a player, how to be
a player with the 40 Yup. Anti.
We've got pull your trophies out.
Don't shoot.
Which I'm assuming is not a gun.
It's kind of a black lives matter.
Then we have a Dr Dre interlude.
I give me back my eyes only
dimes is the track number 13.
That's what Ge z and
then torque the drain.
The dream was on there also twerk trains
and other good when there's a lot of
cuts on this girl. Chanel, west coast or
Chanel west coast. Oh Shit. And then uh,
my favorite, uh, is pop that
pussy. That's a trend I see.
Oh that's the one my mom likes the
most of course. Is that what you think?
That's also a very socially
conscious song about,
about a victim of
prostitution. Not, Oh really?
Who in the end of the song she triumphs.
There you go.
And she pops that pussy,
the pimp and the end.
That's what songs sad for the pimp.
I mean he was doing stupid shit.
Guerrilla pimp. He was being very
strong, too strong. Beat her.
And she ran away and he ran.
He came across her like when I came
across bloods that Betty, yeah,
I killed it with the nut here. He
really tried to fight. Let me mark.
That would be my, that'd be on my app and
be like, get the shot, get the shovel up.
Sang. I love it. You guys
are too short science course.
That was the best part of this whole
thing. It doesn't have super exciting
scary with those eyes
open like, oh yeah, yeah.
There's people who like to wear that stuff
and then they wear harnesses and butt
plugs with like, you know, dog tails
on them. We make fun of that stuff.
Fuck what a dog. Yeah. Yeah. Most of
them have unicorn heads though. Yeah. No.
Ask Your hose. I'm sure they can tell
you some stories. Some pup play stories.
Yeah. Yeah. Pony play. But this was
a thrill. Thank you guys very much.
Thanks so much. Blessed thing of two
short, short dog. Thanks for coming, man.
Appreciate it.
I'll get man
g, G, G,
which one's the gene.